[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
yes sir
[Music]
yes sir
what's going on around
sunday sunday sunday it is the lord's
day you know how we do
what's going on people
see how my levels are sounding out here
getting ready
gerald mack first in the building what's
going on salute to iop you already know
akw what's going on
lydia master what's up you know what i
mean lord metroid what's up
fun speculation what's going on brother
texas in the building what's going on
hope you guys have a good show i
appreciate you man much love on that for
sure
i am mike i am my tyson we got tyson in
the building salute mike
dev mobile what's going on bro good to
see you thank you akw for the level
check you know we do sunday the lord's
day
getting ready you know
this show we got ricardi coming through
coming through
you know
coming through
just gotta make sure uh see what's going
on king might be on is on vacation you
know what i'm saying well deserved well
deserved
but uh yeah he would definitely miss
we're gonna have a fun show we got some
surprises and things you know what i'm
saying
getting ready a little memorial day
give you a little something you know i
mean we could have took the time off but
i know king king definitely needed it
so we wanted to give him the time but uh
yeah we just gotta do a little something
get the legendary ricari in here have
some fun on the sunday the lord's day
dallas man what's up what's going on i
see you brother mr ordinary holler
mexican zoidberg what's up awful grim
bones let's get it imax you say what's
up son the iop indy 500 f1 oh yeah
racing dude caller 600 seven less sound
okay okay
you ready i'm actually ready i like it
so yeah we're gonna go get
makari up in here and um yeah he said
david don't get yeah yeah yeah he's
chilling he in the beach somewhere he's
doing it real big right now
oh angle was chicago in the building
real console oh you're a real customer
he said
[Music]
come on man put the guns down
here for peace
anyway look hopefully get everybody in
the building have a fun show and i will
see you all in a bit
[Music]
[Music]
so
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they're
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers they don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beating they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal but they'd be like why use a
video game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger that's
who
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
fire this is that yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tiller uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to starter regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
um look i guess you could say that i'm
very spoiled for them to be your dog
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boil you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
i'm better than money because you can
bank on me being accountable i know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start it regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social
[Music]
hold you i ain't here to boil you you
ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed for
you i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame
um
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with
the gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um
we are
live
iron lord podcast
lord cognito here talking about the
latest with advanced gg there's a lot of
things going on with the new product
line let's get right to it
so we got that focus line this is that
standard this is what we use right now
kind of our caffeine substitute and what
we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing its focus on deck number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta adeline so you don't get the
jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know car
glove is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to advanced gg.com use code iron lord on
the checkout this is something i use all
the time got to support advanced gg
great products if you want to get your
workout on even if you don't work out
you're just gaming you need that focus
and again the hydration line for those
who don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lord
cognito here iron law podcast
peace
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for attic
if i can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty ain't not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be me
though i know it's my destiny worth the
cognito who cares if you fly if you
steal a mosquito you swear you ain't
something but really
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that you can't never
still be the king of the statues since a
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle
[Music]
check right quick talk real quick solve
if you see something see something move
hello yeah there we go here we go
all right here ye hear ye and we are
live
welcome to the iron laws podcast llc and
also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 259
and it's another glorious sunday we're
back at the round table on the lord's
date i'm very excited about our special
guest and we've got playstation games on
pc and mobile
xbox turning down marvel
and tcl mid-gen refresh leaks to discuss
so we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who is not
only a true ambassador for community
management and interviews within games
culture but his unique skill set of
hosting and entertainment always shine
on the biggest stage
introducing the senior community manager
at gamestop and former product marketing
manager at xbox
the lord of all seattle sports and
dragon ball tattoos
whose shoe game has quietly leveled up
as one of the best in gaming
live from washington and finally making
his debut into the realm of the lords
my man lord rikari how we doing sir man
all gas no brakes
first of all
about two shades lighter i'd be blushing
[Laughter]
i could see this spirit i can see this
spirit
right here
see that's just it none of the heat i
just get what i want oh
good to have you man good to have you so
obviously he was rocking out at pax
easter so he was good to see you working
and stuff like that doing your thing but
um yeah long overdue man big fan and um
what you've been playing man what's
going on what's the games have been like
for you
nothing warzone
warzone with you know
i very much evolved into a social gamer
throughout the years uh we can blame the
pandemic and all that but
i mean i just i hop online when my
buddies hop online i do destiny dailies
every now and again um i'm finding my
like sort of indie niche like i've been
playing pokemon arceus just randomly at
night but it's like 30 minutes here and
there
and then warzone is the one where i
still get the good the session yeah
yeah well it's cool but i got to get
that going they got new content coming
or what what we should do are you still
waiting for the for the next joke
because we already hear the rumors of of
the the next iteration so to speak yeah
you know really again it's it's about
the friends so the friends jump online
and say we just play in this little mode
all right let's do it you know get to
hang out with the knuckleheads
and do the things for the content
not to say the content can be stale but
it's never been about like destiny i'm
definitely chasing the carrot right i'm
like i gotta get this new exotic weapon
i gotta go you know do this yes warzone
is just everybody hops online i'm like
let me hear the bs that my friends
let me see who's raging who's doing this
and let's go get a couple of dubs
no doubt that community battle royale
right
no doubts you already know are we
supposed to have four horsemen off game
inside the two horsemen of the
apocalypse in here
we're missing two horsemen of the fog
wreak havoc just the two of you
one is in the bushes so we gonna call
him out lord addict i don't know what
she was doing last night we're gonna
speak we're gonna speak about the health
leaders in progress we can speculate
right we can speculate and then one is
legit on on vacation so salute to the
king he's out there moving and shaking
right now doing his thing somewhere on
beaches of aruba somewhere sands and his
beard i was like yo what's this
i know he comfortable cause the beard is
just
[Laughter]
when he's with us
salute to the king send some love to him
you know what i'm saying get his rest
and relaxation on but we still have the
most technical gaming lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the
sastradamus
lord carrie of the iron bank my man mr
sovereign how are we doing
i'm good i'm chilling you know just uh
just just just waiting one more weekend
i'm out of here
so you get the move the move is going to
be there yes thank god nice i gotta get
i packed a month ago and here i am
finally moving so this is what happened
but nice i need to i need a little bump
this morning
what you got
oh we got the powder put that up this
it's sweet as hell because i have
definitely more than eight ounces of
water
and it whoa
i am chilling man i am i again i haven't
done much gaming because my consoles are
already put away i have little man out
oh but i haven't had a chance to i
haven't had a chance to plug it in
exactly so i haven't done a lot of that
i got some uh i actually picked up mario
golf and i hadn't done that before and
so i started messing with that you know
those mario sports games are just cool
and fun to play so i and it's funny
i've always seen golf as a game that it
would be fun to play because i like the
minutia of trying to you know
you know you know get get the ball in
the whole piece
pause
but
watching it has never been something i
wanted to do
so you know
so so mario gives an extra layer of fun
to that that i can i can vibe with so
i'm doing that and i like i said last
week i've been doing since i don't have
any time i try to actually stop to read
being that i'm just yeah you know i'm
always up and out and about i fall
asleep so i said okay audiobooks right
so i told you guys i finished reggie's
book and this past week i had started
both of uh uh jason schreier's books and
not finished them because again i just
fall asleep you know pixels and other
ones and uh press reset
so i had bo i got both of them on on
audible and went through both of them
good reads man
it gives you a lot of insight into
you know we sit here sometimes we talk
about oh this game you know all delays
dude everything gets delayed man
hey everything gets delayed everything
is is a hell hole until it's not
and that's just the nature of game
development and i think the more that
people like us
start really realizing that and
incorporating that thinking into how we
talk about games yeah i just think in
general in general i think the
environment will be better because
everything is just a
ball of flame until it's not
and until it's not is usually very close
to release very close to release you'd
be surprised how things come together
last minute too yeah so i i tell you
it's it very good reach just informative
it's just straight facts about a lot of
stuff he doesn't really you know he has
his thoughts about crunch and sort of
the idea of the volatility in in in
gaming how people just have to be
uprooted every couple of years because
studios closed and stuff like that but
yeah
it's crazy the curtis
38 studios yeah that was a crazy
situation it was because he you know
kirsten approached that situation from
the the point like you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna apply what made me successful
to this game studio right and in theory
like he gave what he gave them bro they
were excited you see them
he didn't realize he just didn't know
understand the dynamics of what it took
to really make a game and and you know
and then he started sort of
interjecting himself into the
development process and be like oh this
would be cool like yeah
let's just add flying amounts to this
game
yeah it'll be easy you know things like
that so it's a very interesting read
because it just it just gives you
insight
into a lot of stuff that a lot of us
assume when we talk about this stuff and
it's better to be well informed that's
what i've been doing no doubt no doubt
hey i did not expect to be out here
buying books but now i'm like they'll
sound awesome
they're good good
big very good reads because they give
you insight it's 38 studios um what the
heck else um all the stuff that went
down with hanger 13 the mafia people the
bioshock um so irrational games a lot of
stuff that
if you recall that was a point there was
there was there was this point in time
they were it was just like studios are
closing like left and right
and a lot of it just had to do with you
know
kind of
auteurship sort of kind of taking over
the the the game development process in
a way they sort of blew things out and
there was no sort of direction and sort
of
finite points to things and
it's just it's just a very interesting
thing because when you start looking at
how things are trending now
uh you look at ken levine kelly's newest
game still has not come out and we're
going like eight years or something like
that
so it's one of those things where it
just gives you a lot of insight onto wow
i i assume this i assume this and it's
just not the case at all yeah we're
gonna talk real talk definitely good
read that i caught that up for the
destiny stuff just see how that came
together as well
oh yes
no doubt should i say solves but pretty
much that's it man that's pretty much it
no doubt of course we have the gaming
ninja himself this [ __ ] nobody lord
cognito spreading that realism around
our iop not telling what you want to
hear what you need to hear shout out to
mr maddie plays the following duke
should be up now on youtube for last
year media we had a good good talk about
whether gameplay should be canceled or
not the streets are talking it's crazy
people yelling down recurring rolls up
streets streets are talking about their
rear ends
the twitter streets is hot everybody got
a spicy take about this i definitely was
a little spicy this one so go check that
out i had a lot to say there i have more
to say later here but um yeah go check
it out we also talked you know
acquisition talk all that stuff shout
out to the last word you bought this ty
got travis talking that destiny talk
season of the hunt haunted we've been
talking about that how we feel likes
dislikes you know what i mean what's
going on there and then um yeah as far
as me it's been yeah destiny season
started that i haven't done the new
dungeon yet i got to check that out
people been talking um you know that's
good so i got to see and then um on my
vr game getting d me already because you
know we got new stuff coming new content
coming i'm absolutely loving that game
new um adventure as well it's like a new
uh character in the game coming so i
want to get prepped for that but um yeah
that's what i got right now so i was
gonna do the um describe it a month and
then all you want to do
real quick before we go to scribe of the
month um
in the spirit of king's absence let's
talk quickly about fights last night my
bad yes yes in the spirit of k combat
talk yes yes yes shout out to giovant
right tank
tank davis versus uh uh rolly romero um
there was a lot of a lot of that talk
going into this fight uh rolly is the
young up-and-comer very strong big boy
it's very good to see tank sort of get
past that that early sort of hubris
point when you're young and you just
think you he he's he's called tank for a
reason right run through
you can see he was very much a more
seasoned measured fighter he realized
that rowley was a bigger dude than him
and
one thing that i learned from from
wrestling is that when you're wrestling
a dude that's bigger than you because a
lot of times i would go into matches
where
dudes were my weight class but it was
you know 150 pounds of muscle yeah it's
different
so it's like
you know when they when somebody shoots
in on you they tell you you know
you sprawl right yeah but a lot of times
the best thing you can do if you're fast
and you're very good and i was you know
i i wasn't that
but if you can
catch that guy's momentum moving forward
and like use a wizard or something to
get to use his momentum against him and
put him on his face
that's what the smaller guy has to do
use the guy's forward movement his
momentum against him and that's exactly
what tank did yesterday it was
reminiscent of you know
ricky hadn't checked hook with with
floyd
or manny pacquiao and mark marquez when
he ran it because this dude ran into the
joint he literally ran into a punch that
it was like a quick check hook that he
kind of moved out the way put it right
in his face boom and that was it um and
you know that smart fighters you know do
that and again sometimes you look at
tanki like oh man he's not focused like
that but tank he's been learning and he
is he's definitely a veteran now and you
could see that in his movements and how
measured he is he doesn't make a lot of
stupid mistakes and and shout out to him
because uh you know king predicted that
he would go down because he wanted to
see something
he would have played he was upset but uh
i didn't like the fact rolly don't do
that yeah come on take your
don't run decline the interview because
you were doing a lot of talking bro like
you were doing yeah you're a lot of
talking so but that he was definitely
the biggest puncher the tank is has
faced yes um and so far you know he he
passed that test but there you know
there are some dudes like shout out to
the logic ones in the chat tio fimo
shakur
there's some dudes overcoming that again
tank has to show that sort of that
veteran sort of guile and be able to
sort of i
the ref gave him so much time like yeah
his legs like that
my mind wanted but my body said no there
was no did you see he there was no
argument there's no argument
usually when you when you're like no i
can go there was no response because he
wasn't there yeah they they
that referred to let him back in there
there wasn't a body in the street blood
on his head he needed help getting back
to the locker room so he no oh no he's
elijah keeping the razor my bad i got a
rep for my cue bottle
we need your brain cells please so
anyway but yeah man great fight great
fighter check that out and um yeah man
uh real quick while you queue up it's
that time of the month you know what we
do launchinggaming.net has been blessed
some tremendous writing talent shout out
to all the scribes had a great long
night meeting yesterday with the entire
team a lot of new additions a lot of
hungry people you know for the team just
making content and we're moving to
shaking man so we got to celebrate the
team but we do want to celebrate one
particular writer who kind of went above
and beyond in the month of may my
brother has been killing it with the
lord's minute with king on a pop culture
and i think he had like a she-hulk one
that they did it actually was so good
that attic put it up on it on the um on
iop and it did well for us so absolute
to him he always does good destiny
coverage and he's just always in the
game man good combination of video
production as well as um audio stuff so
we proudly present the winner of the
lord dizzy lognet scribe of the month to
my man the prince lord ty swenson what's
going on bro now i know he could not be
here to accept his award we have to do
it like the oscars he could not be
accepted
killing god's killing it killing it like
ty ty has an entire wardrobe of
t-springs
he's killing it and it's to the point
like you know
i want to be clear though
these awards are competitive you know
what i'm saying very much yeah shout out
to the editorial team shout out to
everybody you know that that's been
reviewing the work it's it's not easy
because we got talent bro and it's
always close but yeah a lot of
a lot of people in there hustling man i
i cannot i cannot stress how grateful we
are for the work you guys do because
again it's from the heart nobody's
getting paid yeah it's just for the
passion of of the work and you know and
to be honest man a lot of times people
get this sort of
they get a little bit sort of
disgruntled by the fact that you know
you're not getting paid you're not
you're not ign yet or whatever the case
may be but it's it's just for the love
and the passion that you're doing
awesome brother and the key thing is
giving people opportunity almost like
you know get their voice out the triple
a double a call up you know what's it
mm-hmm and we've and we've given people
that opportunity we're going on to move
on to windows central that's going on
and move on to an ign and stuff like
that so you know look we love what we're
doing we got to salute our team shout
out to lord ty's probably chilling on
vacation right now but well deserved as
well make sure you hit up soft get you
get your swag get your log the iop free
stuff from the shop whatever you need
bro we got you we got you let's get
these super chat today let's get uh take
care of carter that no doubt so we got
uh start off remember for two months
real console warrior shout out to you
sir put the crest in the chat but it was
a real console
xbox tweeted scale bound why really
just did that oh hell no oh man somebody
checked that somebody check that let's
make sure that's a real deal make sure
it's official i don't know about that
mm-hmm
it's not it doesn't say xbox.org
then we got render two dollar super chat
king got flown out by phil spence
your kid with the dominance right there
chilling and we got the homie heart
chinese member for 12 months thank you
sir brother salute to half the lords
just fine
no king with all these xbox stories man
enjoy the r and r king welcome to the
realm of khari and maybe we should fix
the spelling for his name and we did
that already yes we did that because
quickly corrected me
i don't know what i was doing with the
youtube yes ricardi for a moment that
you were no you don't even worry you
were rakiri foreign
you know devon cooper here
[Music]
[Laughter]
shout out to you sir thank you brother
and we got gaming forte five dollar
super chat work is more bearable when
the lords can help you to your day have
a great show gentlemen thank you my
brother that's fellow game stopping the
bill the gamestop manager detroit in the
building what's going on forte what's
going on and we got jd gamer 2 super
chat good day lords hit that like button
folks yes hit that like button we got
320 watching right now
shout out to asa he said someone
retweeted the scale bound thing from
2015. so they pulled up a 2015 xbox
tweet talking about
it's like it's just popping okay i see
what's going on
so we all said well yeah
cool let's get into it so you already
know that uh ricardo has been patient
we've got into what everybody's been
playing but we gotta focus on laura
ricari his video game system history his
journey into hosting that xbox and of
course what led him to the senior
community manager at gamestop so lord
rakari let's start from the beginning
man what were some of the first video
game systems you had and what got you
into gaming
i mean it was just the thing that you
did right first system that we had at
the house was a
nintendo yeah
like the og nes um
but my pops was big on back or pac-man
galaga what was the what was the top
damn little airplane shooter again
whatever was in the laundromat
that's what we played top down uh 1943.
yeah i think it was 1943. i mean i never
knew the name i just knew i was like hey
man let me hold the quarters i'm gonna
be over here and he'd be next to me
playing pac-man i'd be playing that so
gaming was always just
you know i didn't have to grow up in a
time where gaming was not around
you know it was becoming the hype thing
and then yeah i think i was uh
six years old at my birthday and i
remember we were at skate king this
little place a little roller skating
rink out here and they had this is how
long ago this was they had super mario
brothers on the arcade machine wow
[Applause]
like you could play it at the little and
it was a weird it was like a pole with
like a little
tv looking screen almost like the same
ones they had at mcdonald's sitting on
the pole and you'd play there
and then i remember sitting there eating
my cake i was mad as hell because there
was i i see the picture in my head it
said you know happy birthday daddy's big
boy and it was a ninja turtle on it i'm
just setting uh how old i am
and he's got blue right here but he's
holding size and i was like hey yo like
what is this
he got you he got to the aftermarket
ninja turtles
[Applause]
so the box came out about yay big and it
was the nes the double pack right the
the cartridge that had super mario
brothers and duck hunt on it and it came
with a little gun too and that's all she
wrote we would just play that all the
time nice um ended up picking up double
dribble and dumbbells dribble yeah
double trouble with that game
that's it
so then from there like
with the nes did you like kind of just
stay in the ecosystem for a while or
where like other systems continually
introduce to the to the house
i can't remember so my brother's 12
years older than me i can't remember if
he took the nes or if i got to keep it
but it wasn't long like if i got that in
92 when i'm about six
i mean snes ended up coming out
right um i don't know if we had one i
don't know what happened to nes but i do
remember actually with hitting like
94.95 let's go i'm at uh
i'm at this like supersonic
season ticket holder party because this
is this is where we get let's go let's
go my mom used to date sam perkins wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
yeah
game one versus the bull yeah
yeah
that's crazy wild right it was still
wild that i still get to talk to him but
she was going to hang out with him okay
this is the crazy their first date was
the night that sonic's lost game five in
the playoffs to the nuggets and the ken
bay is on the ground
one of the greatest upsets y'all was up
to oh my god so i wasn't old enough to
understand that part of it i was just
sad that sonic's lost but she went to
this charity event it was at this little
pool hall down here yeah and i couldn't
get in
i couldn't get in because or she
couldn't either because you had to
purchase the ticket to the event to go
in and she's like that's not why we're
here anyway they ended up purchasing
purchasing a ticket i had to play pool
against nate mcmillan i ended up beating
him
who's this kid in here nine years old
beating you know reading the sonic and
they were like we're doing this video
game thing and i promise it'll come
around about let's go uh and i was like
well what do you get or the what do you
mean this video game things like we want
to hook you up with a couple of video
games from like cool it was nba live 94
in nba all right uh and excuse me live
95 madden 95. yo hold
let me start this real sports talk now
live 95 though what is it kind of not
isometric like the diagonal one that
that was like 95. oh that was like 98.
oh that was 95 was still was still side
to side up and down who was on it was it
shaq and nick anderson i can't remember
smith so i just remember 95 being like
one of the classic ones though you know
what i mean we gotta go with that no it
was uh it was jack and hakeem shaka the
key yes yeah
what yeah and live 95 was still was
still uh uh what's isometric
it was right oh it was you're right yeah
yeah yeah right it was isometric pixels
yeah yeah 9-5 was a big one man that was
a big one what so they gave you those
yeah but they gave them to me on an snes
and i remember being like yo genesis is
coming
i snuck because this was december 21st
[ __ ] that's all i can saw that i'm you
know i'm getting the genesis oh i
low-key
[Applause]
and now that i got a son that's nine
years old i'm like this boy is terrible
at lying and i think back i was like i
probably was too like they probably were
watching me like what is he doing yeah
you said you swear you were a genius but
you know i got it listen man so that's
that's when i got my console like there
was no older brother in the house
anymore he had long since graduated got
out of there
genesis was my first one hands down
let's go let's talk some genesis talk
right here let's give flowers i i
personally think genesis is i mean
dreamcast is to be
like their pinnacle what they could be
but as far as what was actually
successful them and the run that genesis
had and being that you're a sports guy
kind of like me people don't realize
like you said you made a key point
genesis was the de facto sports console
between the two because the i remember
the ea ports just ran
better you know what i'm saying like
whether it be the lakers first cell just
nba live all the stuff just ended up
running better so like give me some some
key genesis titles that had you
what had me what's funny is i remember
one of my first games was power rangers
fighting game then i got nba jam nba
gmte college slam um
what else did we have on there there was
a game called super high impact
i don't know if you remember that it was
like it was like nfl blitz before nfl
blitz
with crazy announcers and all that it
was blitz just it was it was if uh oh
god why am i forgetting bo jackson
what's the game what's the football game
oh gee the og was tech bowl right yeah
so it was like tecmo both sort of look
like the way they lined up on the field
yeah but with
nfl blitz style gameplay oh okay 3d but
like that sort of look what else did i
play shinobi was one sonic i was
terrible at those games though um of
course it was a lot of nba jam and a lot
of college slam mm-hmm the nba and yeah
nfl like the sim type games and then a
boy up the street he had a second
channel
he was rich playing that fifty dollar
job to go play echo the dolphins so i'd
always be at his house playing whatever
i could fire [ __ ] did you have a psychic
channel
no i'd come to your house
my mom was like what's this
yeah the most i had was was x-band when
that was like their first introduction
you put that little contraption on top
of the genesis and you're able to you
had your little your little modem and
you tried try to play just make sure
your balls ate on the phone you don't
say all live versus somebody okay so
genesis okay now that's your console so
they're from genesis like wait what did
you move on to
what was next all right then
you know it makes sense that i work at
gamestop now i want to say was something
with like funko land back in the day and
i can't remember i know my parents had
to take me but i ended up jumping back
and forth between
snes and genesis a couple of times like
i really fell in love with super mario
world and nice
i didn't spend a lot of time with snes i
mean you guys all understand this one i
don't remember if i had the consoles or
if the neighborhood had the console
right because we lived in that sort of
neighborhood or if one person had it you
just brought it to the boys and girls
club or the y and we all had it so we
would trade and flip-flop back and forth
and play whatever we could
um but then it turned into
funny thing we talked about sam perkins
and that i remember being at his house
and he was like yo you ever check out
this thing called the playstation
and i was like
like that's that boy that used cds i was
like hell no that was like 500 bucks
and so
you know we jumped into the next gen
stuff i ended up getting an n64
what
in 98 whenever it came out like
two or three months later i think it
came out in september or october i got
it for christmas maybe that year in the
next year
that was the next console and then it's
just been everyone since yes like
you know funko land gamestop eb whatever
became a thing where i was like i'm
gonna just go trade and flip flop and
get this one yeah yeah
um no it's real
okay so what were the standouts on the
n64 for you cause we would
super mario 64 was the one star fox i
still love star fox to this day okay nba
inside drive inside drive yeah
yes 10 10 frames a second
yeah yeah ten frames yes yes what else
i'm trying to think of whatever none of
the wrestling games we were big in the
wrestling games
so those were the ones you know we
talked about the the friend my friends
owned them gotcha i never did got you so
hey get this i spent years my favorite
job was working on killer instinct right
i grew up to that point hating fighting
games because i just never owned them
and your boys are playing mortal kombat
in the house and yeah you know there's
10 people in there and you lose real
quick again you got to go to the back
rotation
bro
you're always the one giving up the
sticks yeah yeah come see me
jam
[Laughter]
no i never jumped into the wrestling
games or things like that because i just
never i never had them like i remember
that uh what was the wwf one that had
the black cartridge yes yeah all those
things i was like nope i played turok i
played a bunch of characters oh yeah
that's where i found my love of shooters
goldeneye was another one um perfect
dark
yeah perfect dark was on there too now
you're saying a lot of sports but we got
to see like
where were you at with madden well how
poor was madden to you or if was it
import not important to you
uh madden let's see here any maddens
over the years or or just you just
really didn't rock with mad and too
tough i would play them all in like 95
you just be the cowboys and run uh the
four verticals or you know you run hail
mary
yeah
you just run streaks and they're gone
it wasn't
again i'll reference the you know
section 8 type neighborhoods and whatnot
and getting all the kids together you
had to play things that were quick fast
right right we would it wasn't mad and
it was blitz gotcha
you got like four two minute quarters
yeah people could play yeah right you
were getting off uh
you know tony hawk was a big one too
because again four people go at once two
minutes rotate good point so madden
wasn't really there and in the same vein
nba games weren't really there until
about 2010 we they just had to be arcady
if they were arcadian you could do it
quick cool if not
gotcha because then everybody could kind
of get a rotation get a rotation gotcha
i feel you to roll back for a second to
the genesis did you get did you ever
place uh joe montana sports talk
football no no it might have been before
him yeah
yeah that's true yeah it was to me that
was it was it was side scrolling yes but
it was it was one of those it was there
was no license
but
the idea that you had a play-by-play
commentator
no matter i mean he was very robotic and
the the plays every time you made a play
it would zoom in yeah on the pixel you
could like if you were running like if
you were running the ball in with the
with the with the running back like it
would zoom in on you and there was slow
motion where you could see the jukes and
you could see
it was like
damn tennis it was like it was like uh
what's it called when you dunked it was
like yeah
yeah like you know what you guys
but the is yeah the thing about it that
that song was also
talking about is that like that was the
first time we really heard commentary in
a game yes right and it now granted if
you look back at it now it's very
robotic montana with the pass two yeah
first down that that you know
but we were like we're just blown away
that the game was talking like it was
just revolutionary for its time and to
to solve credit but like i said when
they zoomed in the graphical fidelity we
like oh my god the sprites oh my god you
could see all the animations i'm like
wow they really put a lot of work into
this non-licensed game yeah
man oh for sure and for baseball they
had the same too yeah
no doubt no doubt so
that just that reminds me of the 64. uh
and on the snes ken griffey jr's ken
griffey yes
yeah i would cheat i would cheat
king junior's winning run but
in the snes version right they had two
codes um because they had eight players
that were in the
home run derby so first code that you
would enter is the fast running okay so
you had to actually press pause to enter
the cheek though so i'd be playing next
to somebody and i'm like hey what'd you
say floyd and i'd pause
and put in the code and come back and
bunt
dudes will be getting mad like why can't
i ever throw him out or do it take off
like was it kenny lofton just
[Applause]
and then i would do that until there was
a second sheet in that game to where
you'd hit an automatic home run so long
as one of the people that was in the
home run derby wow
yo so wait you mean to tell me the cheat
would allow to be in competitive play
you could do this to the competitive
player there was just the game just the
game yeah yeah that was it wow i never
knew this i'd never do this no esports
rules it was just
he was just pulling a fast one on them
was there like a sound indicator that
know that that you knew that you just
okay this is when cheats were tough too
you didn't know until you actually got
up there that it had to happen that is
so you really i mean so what was the
button comment i'm not that
was it a long combination of buttons it
wasn't like zero zero three six five six
oh i forget mics but it wasn't that long
but it was probably about five or six
buttons a couple of directions and a
couple of buttons on the uh so you had
to really pull that off while they were
just distracted for a couple of seconds
that's all it took was a couple of
seconds
i thought he called me
yo i love it i love it i i never knew
about this this is new to me i'm gonna
look that up so the kate griffith right
salute no doubts you go through all of
that i know we moved forward you
mentioned sam perkins with in the
playstation stuff like that i also want
to know um did dreamcast get in the mix
for you as well before we get to the
place yeah okay yeah uh you know what's
at 99.99
i remember this is where i learned about
you know uh credit cards and all that i
was like how do i buy this oh it's
letting me order
i'm gonna pay with a money order i want
to go ship it first
yeah that's where you learn about tax
like oh i got i got the i got the 199
but this is tax thing yes i'm in eighth
grade like i need this but again i got
lucky my you know my uh grandparents
parents knew i was gonna you know
interested in it and i got one for
christmas nice night off the bat you
know nfl 2k first thing i did was when
made my little eighth grade football
team we all had blacked out visors
because you could nice yeah i created my
team the greenwood spartans put our
visors on okay and then what else did i
get sonic adventure that was that's the
one i liked sonic before i would play
sonic 2 sonic 3 on the dream or excuse
me on the uh genesis but
adventure was too fun yeah and then um
power stone this is the first time i got
into a fighting game but because it was
a four player
like kind of royal rumble kind of
free-for-all type yeah yeah
and yeah those are my joints on there
you remember the demo discs right
remember
you get that double disc
that's that's where i first picked up
tony hawk oh okay it was on that and i
played that demo disc until like the
little you know the little [ __ ] stuff
from the front came off
and i was like all right i'll go buy the
cable
bill ricardo disc sweat everything back
in the day oh my god i paid ten dollars
for a magazine so i could get the demo
there
magazine yeah yeah yeah that's right i
got that demo desk demo this shout out
to ryan mccarthy oxm magazine back in
the day i remember that man demo dish
really that was the thing that was if
you're from that era like that was the
you you cherish that especially it was a
game you were looking forward to and
anticipated really really cool so then
you move on get that playstation you
know any standouts from the playstation
that you remember cd console why am i
forgetting the name of the uh
snowboarding game
does that want to play with cool borders
cool borders
that was a fun one um chat moto was
another oh i love jeff motor moto is
fire yes oh what else did we play all
right so this is gonna sound wild but we
ended up modding our playstation and i
played the hell out of whatever whatever
you talking about modding playstations
yeah we never did that the statues the
limitations is up
you can talk about it
um what else it was
any ridge racer any let me see
i mean
uh well what are you doing like fight
against yeah which one uh little
fighting driving game twisted metal
twisted metal shout out we had jeffy on
the legend yeah yeah see and look this
was the tough part about all these
things is
back then i had all the time in the
world to play games and none of the
money yeah that was just a few that i
really played good point if it wasn't
the demo disc it was you know i had like
three to five a console once we get past
2004 and i get out of high school then
then we're really going to jump into
some games but
you know playstation it was let's go
kind of just whatever was out whatever
we could all play i mean it was still
like the blitz 2000s and things like
that you start to explore your buddies
that get into cars and all of a sudden
you're playing gran turismo at their
house
i had the buddies that the same buddies
that had like the wrestling games they'd
be over there playing final fantasy and
i'm like all right you go ahead i'm
gonna you know be over here playing
whatever yeah it reminds me that's
that's me
they wanted to get the x-com off and i'm
like all right i'll be over here
but it was still a lot of man i was i
was heavy sports until i got out of high
school just because that's all i knew
right
so so at one point
there was
ricari the potential
player sports athlete
track at one point right
yeah oh okay okay i'll see we'll get to
that so you continue on and then from
there is it just like every console
going on from you know playstation and
also like when did xbox come in into the
pitch for you so i got my first xbox in
2003. okay
it wasn't 2001. i what i wasn't aware
boys and girls club got one so we were
close enough to microsoft i won this
little program called youth of the year
okay and um
you know it was a boys and girls club
thing i never realized we were at risk
youth like i didn't know that was a
thing yeah you know well i knew it was a
thing but i was like we're not at risk
what you mean
so now that i'm older i'm like oh what
the hell how not how did we make it but
i see where we could have turned left
and not been
you know doing what we're doing today
anyway absolutely put on all these
programs microsoft sponsored it um i won
youth of the year for my club went and
competed in the county
and part of the sponsors prizing was for
the
12 kids that made it to the county level
they all got xbox bundles
so i remember we had that but like you
know in the months before this guy came
in he's like you ever heard of this game
called halo i'm like nah what's halo
yeah that was a wrap exactly that could
be a whole two hour
podcast by itself yeah yeah
but yeah we got that xbox bundle and i
had nfl fever let's go uh fusion friends
yes halo was in there it was already
like it's not platinum hits but whatever
it was
um
but everything was in there and then
yeah that was that was the one where i
was really
into gaming if you will yeah access to
more consoles more games i was actually
working summer jobs and whatnot so i had
money to buy things fire um
five whatever came out i was sort of
playing tony hawk american wasteland no
that was later that was two that was
good okay what was 2003 there was oh
thug tony hawk underground came out yes
i mean i still love tony hawk to this
day so there was just a lot of stuff
again still sports and party heavy but
that's really where i was like all right
this is this is a console that i truly
love yeah
bro now salute i mean
man just to hear the story of how how
you got connected to the xbox ecosystem
in the program and stuff like that
absolutely fire and then like
how did you carry that heavy system
that system was big bro i'm not a little
dude
what i could do and i was like all right
but again we would bring it to the boys
and girls actually my first xbox got
stolen from the boys oh
i know terrible terrible buddies came
through and got me one um a replacement
that's how i got that crystal green one
but yeah we would always just
i had the console in the sports games
a couple of guys had a couple of random
games and we would just
bring that xbox and play all day
all day all night i guess it was better
than us being out in the you know the
streets doing other dumb stuff but yeah
the staff used to stay with us sometimes
like we would do late night till
midnight wow we're not leaving there
until 2 a.m fire fire that's funny
that's that's us that's crazy it's us
but it's different because it's at the
boys and girls center but it's like it's
what we were doing like playing till 2am
and yeah i one thing that really
resonated with me that you said is just
the fact that
you're
you're an at-risk youth as we were yeah
but you don't realize it because that's
just your day-to-day that's your life
right
you know we were used to the fact that
our lives were our lives were dangerous
day in and day out right and we did
everything that we could do to sort of
remove ourselves from it we weren't
blind to it but at the same time
at my house like i just i just there was
never this this feeling like we're
lesser than or there there wasn't
anything to sort of compare it to so
it's just my life
and that's it and you you know like you
said
things could have gone left on a number
of different occasions and for us like
again we've talked about this you know
on the on this show for a long time but
it's the fact that we had that place to
go to as a group to you know cogs house
and stuff like that really allowed us to
to take a different path but you don't
you know a lot of times you don't
realize it my family was very good i was
a cogs family as well about just
this is your normal life with you know
and and it's just there's nothing out
there's nothing about it that kind of
stands out as
your day in and day out is super
dangerous
and you just sort of get used to it
which i don't know how bad that is but
for us it normalized things it just
normalized things yeah for us it was
more so like
me kind of fighting with my mom because
it was just kind of like you know you
get mad when we out in the street you
get mad when we're doing whatever but
now we're here playing games in front of
you you know i mean yeah we get
rambunctious to get competitive but at
least you know where we are and that was
the argument
yeah to kind of win it over so yeah and
i'll salute to you man that that's
i love hearing stories like this it's me
got that og and i'm assuming continue on
with that 360.
yeah that's what popped up next and so
by this point um let me see 2004 i
graduated well okay 2004 i left high
school so that's when i you know did
that adult bid that's when you realize
your money is your money you can do what
you want yes um don't get a report to
nobody else i'm out the house and yeah
2005 the 360 came out so i ended up
buying two of them
got lucky with you know the gamestop
reservations i got lucky i ended up i
was working t-mobile in like sales
like selling phones and whatnot and i
was all of miles away from microsoft so
everybody wanted data phones this is
right when the sidekick was holding on
i'm 18 19 making more money
blackberry so i'm like hell yeah i want
two xboxes why not yeah i mean
with the red ring of death you needed it
before we knew that was coming that's
true so i i ended up selling one of them
to actually his name was mikey moore one
of the guys that played on the sonics
because i knew all of them and whatnot
yeah so 360.
everything that launched i bought
because again i didn't you know what was
my i had disposable income i wasn't
saving i wasn't thinking about nothing
but me my rent oh my god i remember my
rent when i was 18 was 280 oh
man i got to come out today
my mortgage is not that bad you know
i know what's happening with somebody
before things got crazy and what i
didn't know was less than desirable area
now it's a great area but um yeah
renting out an extra room from him we
paid 780 a month total oh it was the oh
you was living it was living
here you did what you did with the two
where the second console went that's
what
he said he sold this oh you sold the
joke okay so i bought this for 400 and
you mean to tell me i could sell it for
you flipped it okay you're made for the
sonics my bad yeah you're right yeah
yeah that's crazy and you're like he got
the money so hit 800 please thank you
flip that oh yeah he got the right thing
that's crazy that's great salute salute
yeah man 360 stand down gate so was it
were like the gears was it like um
everything ever before i just
everything that was a shooter i mean it
was just what's hot you know game i was
working in the mall so you're always
talking to people in the mall it'd
always be a game stop trying to figure
out what i need to play i still didn't
branch out a lot it was still sports and
shooters got you um but this is where i
found out that i really enjoyed tiger
woods golf right
and this is where i found out that i
would enjoy other little party games
fusion frenzy 2 ended up coming out what
else did i play a ton of i can see this
i can go verify
what i picked up but it was just
whatever sounded fun that i could get my
hands on i'm almost out there playing
rainbow six didn't love it you know had
rainbow six going which one that was the
the vegas vegas yeah i think i was vegas
okay that was the vegas yeah i remember
okay
with service hunt and all that and then
they had their own yes you playing
either the ghost recon the advanced
warfighter stuff yeah and that one
pissed me off because they had a
gamer score that was uh like a one yeah
it was yeah yeah it was it left you in
an odd number yeah that's not
not
it
yeah i would pick up and play kind of
whatever and you know work that gamestop
trade system wherever i could and
we were just trying stuff back then and
the thing i wanted to mention i forgot
to mention during ogx box was like
obviously the introduction of xbox live
and i'm your sports guy you know a
little bit competitive it's like were
you really in the scene going at cats
like online how loose were you online
all right so you're gonna laugh at this
one i stopped playing sports games after
nba live 2005. this is before the 360
came out okay because i'm running with
the hornets playing the mavericks and
mind you i'm playing online this is
crazy but i got baron davis like baron
davis is dunking on cats this is before
he dunked on you know kirilenko yeah
before the we believe warriors yeah he
was still that dude yeah new orleans
right this is like he looked like ucla
baron yes and i get a steal towards the
top of the key take off turbo let's go
yep steve nash is the only person that's
backing up yeah yeah you're about to get
them
now after this point like i think the
ricky davis stuff had already happened
but we know steve nash is not blocking
it you're blocking nothing
baron davis jumps yeah i'm like cool
show time let's go nba nba live 2004.
yeah live 2005 had the best done contest
i'm like he's taking off he gets blocked
and falls over and steve nash runs down
with the ball that's where he aims
you'll be like you say it officially
like i you know i you know because of
sports i get loud but the loud ain't
yeah that's just big bark don't worry
about that it's when i get quiet that
i'm angry
it had mellow on the disc right you know
hit the little thing took out the disc i
did not play another basketball game
until yeah
jordan on the cover it took that long it
took that long because it turned into
nba jam for me like wait a minute i
can't do this i man i was a stickler
when it came to this ball you could not
have anything in my simulation baseball
game that resembled arcadineness because
it would out same thing i had this
visible income i'm not playing this
anymore no bro
kari i'm so with you because like with
my sports game i'm all about the
authenticity and i feel that's not real
and you know because we watch the games
and we don't damn well steve dash ain't
blocking no he's a poster waiting to
you talk about bd i know what you
thought bd was yeah made it on cats back
in the day he had he he he looked like
he was overweight a little bit but he
had he's only 215. yeah and he had
springs he was just jumping up on
everyone i remember that so yeah like i
i completely
completely empathize with that i'd have
probably threw that disc out of probably
like yeah i'm surprised you didn't break
that disc
that was whatever the anger was just
this here's what gets me about
basketball games even to this day
there's things that you get dinged on
that don't happen in real basketball
yeah and i get that there's something
that's got to go into development to
make it work
but like i'm like this is not how it
goes like i hate playing basketball
games and you see steph yeah running
about to shoot at three so you hit the
little wire triangle whatever you play
on whatever floats your boat and they do
that slow low down the slow load up i'm
like no no just hey dude we want to fly
by where's my fly by button yes
yes
oh this is or the keys is we talking
deep sports like what you know what
frustrate me
is ai defense always being able to stay
in front of you despite how quick your
player or how better stat your player is
or you know what i'm saying that you
should drive me nuts but it's funny you
said that this this is wrong you know
when 2k gets mad at you you'd be like
first one back on defense so your job is
to you know like see where the ball goes
stop ball you stop and ball yeah and if
there's somebody in front of you stop
and ball well you got first man down
yeah so i'm sitting here in my player
doing that and it was like oh you know
leave defensive assignments
they
[Music]
too many times
you know the nba 2k be penalizing you
bro
so when we would play like with my
buddies and we played madden so what am
i
uh one of my boys trey
go the nfl he played he played wide
receiver in college i always beat him in
madden and he gets mad but somehow he
beats me in 2k and we both get mad for
the opposite reasons like this is not
supposed to happen i know you're doing
this i move my guy here we get so proud
i love it man the competitive nature man
so you're doing that 360. so again every
system from that point on there's so
supposed to income you're rocking and
rolling that's cool i want a chance
because we can talk games forever like
you i love talking to you um i do want
to transition so now again it was
requiring a little bit of you know maybe
athlete aspirations but then obviously
you're doing a gaming thing and stuff
like that so like what was the
transition and say okay you know what
you know i want to kind of either get
into some type of community management
or just into the industry was it just a
conscious decision like how did that
transition happen for you look the
athlete thing was just me being a
knucklehead and that's you know earlier
i paused when i said i graduated in 2004
because i did not graduate high school
um
we talked about being
section 8 type kids but i went to
private school
not just not just for athletics just
because that was my debt so then we get
into the daddy's stuff oh
let's get it let's get it you know i
the limitations meant when i was like
seven years old like things i shouldn't
have known right you know my dad was a
less than reputable human being though a
nice guy um
you know there was a point where
how do we say this however we say it
mm-hmm
look it if you would say he just he was
just wild this was just wild you know
when he ended up passing in 2016 i was
like this man has lived lives right yeah
this little his little pimping stint he
owned a restaurant he did all this stuff
i remember waking up waking up and
there's naked bodies all over the house
and porn playing on the tv
dad was outside oh he was moving
boogie nights
then he had to get rushed to the
hospital because they said and i quote
there was enough coke in his blood to
start a small south american country wow
so with all that craziness his thing
used to be my boys always have to go to
private school
okay right they're not going to grow up
to be me even though around not
shielding us from exactly what was going
on right um so that's why i ended up in
private school
and
at that point i was still the
knucklehead kind of section 8 kid but i
never took care of my work incredibly
gifted incredibly talented and just
never wanted to do the thing i got to
argue back with the teachers like why
didn't you do your homework i'm like why
do i need to do my homework it's good
practice for your tests i'm like but i
get a's and b's on your test that way
i feel you know that i'm naturally
gifted why i gotta do all this extra
work this looks into the sports thing
right yeah
i failed a class senior year survey of
british literature uh i got an
incomplete on it but blanchette
maintained 100 graduation rate
so they said you're not on pace you
gotta go
wow
no summer school nothing you just you
couldn't do the summer school to make up
not as a senior no
no if you don't walk day of you're gone
yo that's great i didn't watch what was
in school was this blanchett high school
i've never
you know they not playing out there no
opportunity to fix no wow that's crazy i
know if you're not walking on and you
know we're we're september to june so or
may so if you're not walking like may
25th you're not walking um
wow so i couldn't go ncaa because i
didn't have my high school diploma
which then led to me just working at
t-mobile and you know i'm doing the
sports things and mind you i wasn't
going to be ncaa d1 not off jump not out
of high school what was what was the
position what you was looking at see and
then here's the next problem i'm six
three pushing barely pushing six like i
don't ever want to say i'm six four
because somebody who's really at the
highest point
no you're not
me and steph curry are eye to eye but
he's six three and three quarters and i
know that one so
i could jump i'm baby barkley okay okay
can't really shoot like that mm-hmm and
i'm not super fast but don't let me get
the shoulders get the shoulder lean in
the
you know when i played my little bit in
juco and when i would play like the d2
d3 type stuff yeah um if they put a big
on me all right we're gonna run this
four out and i'm gonna be you know on
the perimeter i'm gonna run by the big
yes mm-hmm because they put a little on
me then i'll go sit back yeah okay oh
okay i got you i see what he was doing
okay but then there was that realness
when you go
and i would practice with u-dub like the
university of washington and you get
somebody who was your height but like 50
pounds lighter and quicker you could
jump you could do that
i mean i knew quick i was like oh yeah
oh no
you know being friends with all the cats
uh who else could be someone who used to
play with all the time like marvin
williams all the time marvin williams
windmilled on one of my boys and i was
like oh oh no
only sitting here in eighth grade or
sixth grade watching nate robinson's
first dunk so i knew
i knew there was levels to it i wasn't
really
i wasn't banking on professional sports
but i wasn't chasing anything else you
got into college
same thing the old knucklehead kicked in
i was like man 9 30 a.m class this is
this is too early
i'm not going i never went to german
class i speak german
not
i got like a d in german and they were
like you never show up i was like but i
did the whole workbook
for all the see my high school and
college experience was to learn that no
matter what your talent level is you
just gotta do the anecdotal things
whether or not you agree with them good
point to prove your work
that's all my my early bits were so when
it comes to that
athletic versus education versus
figuring out whatever i had to do
it was just more so realizing that
not that my stuff wasn't cutting it but
i just had no plan for myself and if
there was no execution along with no
plan i wasn't going to do anything no
that's real brother and i appreciate
your honesty on that because oh yeah i
don't mind that bro like it's funny
listening to you because i like sort of
i can confess it's like so i've always
felt i went you know we went to school
pretty much then from like the third
grade all the way to like junior high
school every class and it was like that
was my problem like my thing was coming
up was i was i was talented i felt i was
smart and i i would be the guy that went
to the last minute and bs through the
the majority of the thing and then show
up at the test and then pass the
important thing and then when you get
into a routine of continually doing that
you start slacking and i look at you
know my brother solving he's like
straight a's like all the way through
honorable like i never would get
honorable because i would be in that in
between part slacking or whatever and i
know what you mean it was it was a
problem for me and i had to break out of
it as well as
you got to get that work ethic right and
it took me time it's just maturity it
was just i was just immature at that
time i wouldn't do it okay so you're
about to jump in no i i relate
completely because for me ricari i i
relate i was you i was the dude that
everything came easily to me and
i was but i was still i wasn't the
knucklehead though i was i was straight
a student i was behaved i was very nerdy
whatever
but it came easily to me so in the back
of my mind there's a lot of hubris like
i don't need to do work hard
i get into boarding school i go to
boarding school
i go from being the smartest kid in the
class to the dumbest kid in the class
in a matter of months and then at that
point i did not have the work ethic to
understand how hard i needed to work
just to be at the level of these kids so
like that so what happens is for me
rather than
rather than buckle down like okay this
is this is where i need to work now
i didn't have an understanding of how to
do that or even that i should do that
because i was pissed off that i just
wasn't that anymore and i and a lot i
squandered so many opportunities because
of that because i just could not ever
resolve the fact that i just wasn't
naturally that talented anymore
yeah you got to put the work yeah you
got to put in work you got to put in the
work and it was very difficult for me
and it was it was you know and the same
with the sports with the sports when it
came to baseball like i was pretty damn
good at baseball and going through
junior high school to high school there
were real opportunities there and in
high school i really got sort of refined
in terms of you know the rules of the
game and playing properly because
over here in the bronx there were a lot
of talented people i would play with in
the summers but it was kind of the wild
west the guys weren't guys didn't know
what it meant to hit the cut-off man and
nothing like that
it was just
a lot of very talented people
from
and what happened was i took a baseball
to the face
and i was never the same after that and
again again it was another thing where i
was like
before i took that baseball to the face
i was this way
and when i came back i would rather than
say okay i need to work this hard now to
get back to where i was and beyond i was
so pissed at the fact that i wasn't that
anymore that i just sort of squandered
it as well so and like you guys said
it's maturity it's maturity
maturity and the ability to grind
grinding and doing something you don't
want to do against the grain that you
know is gonna better you that's
something that not everybody has but if
you do have it or you learn how to how
that you need to do it yeah that's
that's a big big thing yeah the last one
i'll say before i get back to ricardo is
that yeah you realize it it's
a marathon you know saying not a sprint
and sometimes it's not about who's the
most talented is the people who actually
committed and at that time i was not
committed to the consensus
none of that yeah man i appreciate that
that story
hit hard ricardo was gonna say so you're
going through the motions there
now
you now you're doing the t-mobile thing
so like how does gaming come into the
play like how does it come into the
picture you know space and opportunity
right so i did the t-mobile thing until
i really went back to school to try to
play basketball played my little bit
um never took care of stuff you know and
again we talked about that maturity i
just didn't have it but it was fun
basketball was fun um
school was not i would try to do all the
rocks for jocks type classes and
stuff like that and i just i i don't
know like this sounds weird i don't want
to blame it on my upbringing or lack of
guidance
the way they found me to come play juco
balls i was playing in a little league
and i played against an assistant coach
and he was like what are you doing i
don't know
nothing just doing this he's like do you
want to come play at this school okay uh
what's cool all right cool i can play at
a school like it was it was that sort of
ignorance
that
you know when we get into the workforce
type stuff i worked at t-mobile because
i just ran my mouth in the mall i
actually worked at
shout out the leads
get you fitted and i was like across the
hall from t-mobile so i would always
talk to them a bunch of people my age
they were like you'd be good at this got
you and so that's how t-mobile
after i left t-mobile um
i kind of did the you know college broke
kid type thing for a couple of years and
then
what was it i was working at the boys
and girls club then a buddy of mine was
actually he owns a mattress company
um
right so you know in washington state
today if the bag tears open or if
anything is open in washington state
even from the manufacturer cannot be
sold as brand new so he would buy them
by the truck full
like all these things that are perfectly
good torn in transit anyway i knew him
he was doing that and i was like man i'm
gonna go in and help deliver mattresses
because my boys were doing it so you
know you get off work and then all of a
sudden you guys are ready to kick it
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so we were doing that and all
the while all the gaming stuff would
happen i am fortunate to have lived in
seattle
i could go to gaming events real easy i
became known as that first and kid line
or anything halo related okay okay okay
so
halo 2 not that one because i actually
worked at gamestop for those two weeks
in november when it came out but
hollywood
when they did that
uh august 2007 they did the first halo
public preview event at the imax theater
here um like the pacific science center
imax theater and i was like man i'm a
i'm gonna go be first in line for it and
i went and i was first in line for it it
was some crazy thing they let me in to
watch the thing twice and then
from release and that on everything that
was halo related i just i would show up
to so i didn't know i was community
building but i became that kid that was
known as doing that and the staff knew
me um
the employees knew me like i'm talking
the event staff knew me like the dev
employees knew me the people in line
knew me or we knew each other
so we did those for years and years and
years so you go to about 2010 and i'm
still doing a little mattress thing i
had done that for a year or two or
whatever
and it finally came to a point where i
was able to uh
volunteer for the halo forms just as a
community leader right they're just like
hey you seem yeah you seem normal enough
that's literally what you said to me
like you seem normal enough and you're
cool like do you want to come be a part
of this bit and this is like september
2010 i said sure absolutely
fast forward about a year i had done
that not really anything crazy but
batgirl you familiar with that name bad
girl batgirl is her name was kristen
riley okay when i say her name now it's
gonna become very apparent who she is
her name is now kristen booty okay okay
okay yes so batgirl puts out a tweet
that says hey she was the community
manager for age of empires okay at that
time she says hey
i need a forum moderator must be local
and that's all that she put out
and i you know it's twitter i'm like
yeah i'm interested
and then like three days later she's
like are you gonna send me your resume
or what and i was like how do you
remember who i am wow like we had i had
followed her online and stuff um but
what i wasn't thinking about is i was
volunteering for halo and age of empires
is sitting here and they are both
microsoft ips yes so they speak yes so
jeff said you should grab him
got it when she sees me publicly respond
to that so kristin a few days later was
like where's the resume where's the
resume at no joke i sent it to her in
and you know a week and a half later i
had a job uh fire bro
which is cool but i hate like trying to
tell that story to folks because
i can't tell you the road yeah yeah
because three weeks later kristen left
oh wow
so the woman who hired me left and i'm
like what do we do here and they were
like well we need people to you know try
and write something i laugh again
because i got and i dropped out of high
school because of an english class and i
was like i can give it a go yeah and i
tried some stuff there and our next cm
came in and she's like hey you seem good
at this you want to do this and i was
like oh i've never done this before
she's like you ever do like you know
social copy or anything like that and i
was like you mean right on behalf of a
brand no
that's like great
she's like i've been in this game too
long i don't want to do it here's the
keys let's go figure it out together
nice and that's kind of been the career
path since it's just space and
opportunity
wow powerful powerful whatever shout out
to the attic in the building it's like
we're gonna get a mic check for me right
quick good morning good morning sir good
morning how you doing sarah
last night i was having a lot of like
health issues and i took some medicine
to help me sleep oh you're kind of good
bam it's it's 1 30.
now you're good bro we got glad yeah but
let's worry about that working now
you're feeling better feeling better bro
a little bit all right cool so now man
look man
i don't even saw where did we begin with
that like he just dropped
i think the
great thing is that he had from the
onset he had people who were willing to
help him like she you said like she's
hear the keys i'm going to help you now
hear the keys i'm out here keys i'm
going to help you i'm going to teach you
what you need to learn to do this
that's amazing man that that is amazing
because
just for people to see talent in you and
want to help you a lot of times a lot of
people you know
in in the twitter streets you notice
that people see talent and they they do
everything either to not help you ignore
you act like you don't matter or um it's
very rare that you're going to have and
i'm not saying we haven't seen this but
it is rare that you will have somebody
that is in a certain position that
genuinely wants to help somebody that's
coming up to really possibly even
surpass them so it wasn't even for that
it was more so the best bosses that i've
had in any role
don't look at them i mean they look at
the relationship definitely as boss and
work right now but they are trying to
train you
to get out of there yes right like the
best jobs that i've ever had have a boss
who kind of you don't know what they do
because they're giving the shine to all
the people that are working under them
to grow them to move on and move up um
so i got very lucky to have her no that
that's a great point but i also want to
give you your flowers in a sense that
you know
we're not going to minimize the the
drive for you getting out and being
first online at these events and showing
the consistency and showing up so that
you become that face that they see and
they go wait a minute this kid is always
here he's dead wiggle you got to be
humble with it brother this is a big
deal bro i'm gonna tell you that that
was pride that was not
that was not like a i gotta do this to
break into this right at this point i
was still the little section eight kid
from seattle that didn't even think i
could be there got you guys like
i just wanted to be first in line that's
it i'm gonna be number one they're gonna
talk to me the news is gonna talk to me
i'm gonna be on the event
and we're sitting there and i get there
the event starts at seven okay seven or
seven thirty all right we'll tell you
about 10 30 a.m and i'm like this is the
stupidest thing i've ever done
i was like wow like you know ten hours
before this event starts and
hey 12 30 1 o'clock these group of guys
come four or five guys they're high five
and they're like yeah halo this halo
that i'm just quiet one i'm black and
they don't i'm not thinking that i'm
going to be sitting there for that and
then go up to the thing we're here for
the halo thing where should we line up
and when the lady went like right behind
him
[Laughter]
i was down here looking at my phone like
this uh-huh that's right
no
me going to events was like i'm going to
get you yeah bro you're taking it back
for you taking it back well it wasn't
that i was out there trying to do some
noble thing or break in i didn't know
that it was
something that i was capable of doing
not that i doubted myself i just knew
nothing of the industry
no no absolute so you go you get your
moderation or you're doing the the
waypoint moderate you're doing asian
empires you know what i'm saying now the
trajectory what's the next little thing
you're going through because you're kind
of moving through the ranks at xbox at
this point
so
age of empires was a dope one because
again kristen left jen comes in jen says
do you want to learn social
he says the writing bit we're gonna you
know keep letting you do more and more
this is how we do planning oh here's a
video camera have you ever recorded
anything nope let's work on video
editing fire so i'm doing all this and
then 10 months into that job i get a job
offer on 343's team
um this is
october 8th 2012. today halo 4 went gold
is the day i signed my offer
and so i'm officially on that team now
and this is the fun one because not to
say i hated the job
i wasn't ready as an adult we talked
about the
the maturity that you need the maturity
i was not mature enough to be on that
team it wasn't as
public as i thought or i had built it up
to be and i spent i also had a kid yeah
um
i spent that time not loathing it but i
had so much fun with it it was halo
right but it was definitely the one that
i look back on and it's like oh i was
not ready for that i was not ready for
that at all so i did like
eight months nine months on the halo
team and when we split it was an
amicable split it wasn't even like uh
they were like we're fighting to keep
you and we can't and i was like hey i'm
not that mad about it like i know i got
some experience now i can find another
role right um it was a lot of the
vegetables that i was not trying to eat
my faith i was not trying to eat
early on at the time the kid's stuff was
still wild and tumultuous too but
left halo ended up jumping on
xbox social teams so the first time xbox
ever started to reply to tweets gotcha
broadway was just saying approximately
baby well are you familiar with the term
newcastle at all
not much newcastle was the name of the
tent the event that went on at
uh when they announced the xbox one that
day may 21st okay okay
may 21st 2013 so that's when i was on
that team and i remember the
hush as they were doing all the social
listening and they were like hey we're
not going to respond to anything like
that
[Music]
was this way recording was this around
the uh
we trade games
this is this was all tv tv tv
tv tv he announced may 21st be
or excuse me the first the reveal yeah
it was it was the event right before the
e3 show so the tip so the temperature is
like we knock over spots
yeah but then i spent three weeks in
there and they wanted us responded to
tweets and you talk about how your brain
works and when i was like yo
responding to tweets is easy yeah and
they were like well are you going
through each profile and vetting them to
make sure that you can say something to
them i'm like yeah this is gaming like
people are weird or do you know like
weird stuff as long as there's no
nazi propaganda we're good we're good
yeah um and and i remember them being
like well our goal as a group is to
respond to
i think like our high end goal was like
a hundred tweets a day okay each person
i was like okay i'm starting to count
i'm like well over eight hours that's
what eight times six four hundred and
eighty minutes you want a hundred and
eighty tweets and i'm like you want a
tweet every ten minutes i'm like
oh yeah this ain't it
so i spent three weeks there and i just
left i was like i can't do it what are
you gonna do next i ended up getting a
job on the xbox live arcade team xbox
live arcade had happy wars
world of tanks was on the way
um yes those were the ones that i was oh
there was a couple played so many hours
of happy wars it's not even right happy
horse is great no doubt
i don't even know why when it came to
the xbox one i didn't have that like
same drive to play it when i was on the
360. but damn i played that a lot on the
three it was so good it was so good no
doubt no
good
i jumped on that team and we did a bunch
of stuff and then that was actually the
team so they play xbla kind of turned
into this group called launch works and
if you look at three particular titles
there was going to be a studio called
launch works it was killer instinct
actually and uh
powerstar golf and crimson dragon those
were the three launch works launch
titles for the console yes so we were
working on those we had a few different
community coordinators i was on
crimson dragon emily was on power star
golf okay okay and ashton was on killer
instinct and those became like my first
kind of next-gen experiences so we're
doing the normal community management
stuff for that
was a fun game yeah crimson dragon was
fun actually i uh i leaked what
achievements would look like on the xbox
one
in a live stream
playing crimson dragon because you know
you're working with different builds and
different os builds and you don't know
that achievements are baked in yes and
they don't nobody told us that
achievements were on there so it went
bad
there it is next you know that's your
taco article yeah
[Laughter]
yeah i worked on that team in a bunch of
little titles and then i left there went
to hololens
because my old boss jen went there yeah
so she was like you got to come check
out this thing i was like what thing she
goes i can't tell you and i said what
and she was like if you were to take the
job i'm not gonna be able to tell you
until you sign like until you're first
like and i'm like for real oh i'm
intrigued
let's go yeah so they a i remember they
interviewed me and they're like so
imagine there's this box and then the
box is an idea that could be you know
like oh this is great i'm here for it
i did some time at hololens we went
through announce and all that yes and
then the hololens social and community
team actually absorbed the old like at a
level like kudos to nothing was alright
yeah i remember kudos no i remember kudo
well because i was there when it got
announced and yeah yeah kudo oh
i got you guys i got to tell the story
because shout out to kudo i ain't
letting it go
so i'm there and just like you one of
them first in line kids at fan fest and
i flew from i'm like this is my dream to
go to e3 i didn't know how to get the e3
but i knew that they was going to do a
microsoft press conference so i'm flying
out there i'm like kudos like 2015 baby
and um
yeah i beat them and they like look guys
everybody here first of all i'm gonna
hook you guys up i'm gonna get to see
hollow lands and i'm like yo
this is crazy i'm gonna be like he's
like i just show up at this place at
this time tomorrow you know what i'm
saying i'm like
hollow let's everybody talk about yo i
saw it the halo demo
the command deck i'm like oh i can't
wait to my turn so i get there hey kudo
come on say look man i'm so sorry um
kanye was here so he took your spot
bro
i listened to kanye west for like two
bucks i was tight
i got like damn i i get it but i wanted
that spot i just had to tell it continue
just quick question was you with the
hololens team when they did that
minecraft demo on e3 stage
no that was 2016 wasn't it
okay no i so i was yes on that team but
not on that team so what ended up
happening kudo got those xbox game
studios moved under him
so then my old community team that i
left all of a sudden got absorbed back
into this other group that i was with
got you so we all became one giant kind
of community team so i was back in the
fray back in all the folks that not that
i had left behind or moved on and moved
up from just with you know a group of
familiar faces and that's when i got
moved on to killer instinct right now
we're stopping a few years there
that's where we at right now because
that's what i wanted to ask you about
to me
that's one of your magic moments bro
to me you know 2016 you know you come
out
and at this point you know kill instinct
rocking and rolling
you know you already had uh battle toads
i believe reveal the arbiter was already
a character
and then ricardi oh not yet but yes i
know the moment you're talking yes yes
yes the mo and ricardi comes out on that
stage now at that point
was that like your first e3 stage come
out
call out to do a reveal yes
but that goes back to kind of the things
that we talked about earlier like with
the boys and girls club and youth of the
year uh my dad owning a restaurant i've
always been a
loud person i've always surrounded
myself by loud people it's just
we all are who i thought everyone was as
athletes you get interviewed and you're
expected to be loud and not like
you just you talk it's that old
southerner my dad god lee i remember my
buddy that had sega channel his dad used
to pick up the phone and he wouldn't say
hello it'd be speak
like
you know how many times i had to speak
up
i don't care in person wherever we are
so e3 was
easy light work because that's just what
you do
um i remember when they came up to me so
they came up to me in january that's
when they first loaded the idea we could
have rakari up there
my dumpster was like oh you need a black
dude
you know i was comfortable with them
that was probably a career limiting move
and they were laughing like no no no and
our marketing manager nicole foster
nicole foster's a freaking genius like
she's the reason we had terry crews and
crackdown
she's responsible for a lot of the cool
stuff like the wu-tang collab yeah that
was fire yes um not necessarily run the
jewels but yeah she was invited she had
her hands on a lot of stuff and i looked
in the cars like they probably asked you
too huh she's like they did i'm not
doing it
i'll do it so we have done a lot of
stuff for k.i
it was video related right like we would
always release patch notes and i'm like
hey
okay david ellis who at the still works
at 343 yep david ellis would say
um i remember a tweet and i remember
very poignantly he was like what about
the older people that don't want to
watch a video on an article this is back
when articles used to just be the videos
he's like why can't you do the video
along with the notes and whatnot you
know it was accessibility was kind of
coming into the center so i said for k.i
i said hey we always release patch notes
right that are just long drive boring
they're great reads they're technical
reads though yes what if we did video
content along with it and that's where
they're like okay great that's your
project
so i would have to be in the video
working with our creative media team um
you know we would capture the gameplay
i'd talk to camera and make sure i knew
enough about it i didn't know people
were watching that internally and like
oh yeah he could probably do this so we
did e3
and it was
the whole shebang but that was my my
first real
big microsoft one yes i spoke in front
of thousands with the boys and girls
club right never that yeah that was that
and that because you're on stage i
believe it's the general ram right the
general ram character reveal killer
instinct the building goes crazy
and um yeah i just remember seeing your
energy and i was like oh this you know
for me i gotta i can't lie like you know
says the person of color i'm like oh
this is cool
we outside baby we up here you know so
it was really cool to see it i just i
liked your energy and like also you know
i'm a big fight games guys so it's just
like you know so cool to see them get
behind that xbox we need to get more
fighting games please but um yeah like
it was dope but i want to give you
flowers with that because i thought that
was really a moment and i i felt you
know i'm saying from that point on xbox
fans started to recognize your face more
as we saw you now doing maybe more
interviews and more other things you
know behind the scenes
yeah for sure it was it was funny too
because uh you get down there and again
i was i was thinking like we just do
this and addict i'm gonna go back to
that point you made about that minecraft
vr bit
i didn't know
the levels that would reach or whatnot
or whatever
but you get down there they had an
acting coach and they have us doing
warm-ups okay you have to say some dumb
stuff like i own this stage and you're
doing all these bits and trying to be
loud and project and he came up to me
he's like you're good had you been
trained in this i was like
i mean i code twitch
i was like what you mean freestyle off
the top that off the top it was crazy
and i was like this is fun i was like i
know
because of the upbringing and who i've
been around and my mom dating sam and
like knowing rodney stuckey before he
went to leave i still see him all the
time and having buddies that went to the
nba or nfl like i realized
as far as it comes to fame this stuff is
just the same you're just another person
good point who has more eyes on them so
when it came to speaking again i'm used
to cameras and all that stuff being on
and around and yeah
i don't know maybe it's because we were
always in sales my dad with the
restaurant my mom in real estate like
you had to speak to get what you needed
that's right that's right and so we got
up there and i did my bit and i didn't
necessarily think i was
energetic or not everybody has to read
into it and glean what they want to
glean from it but i do remember going
back and seeing that minecraft bit
and i was like oh
let's go i guess
i guess i can do this okay like i
i had never looked at it through that
lens of how am i doing comparatively
right and it turns out and this is i
will fully say it's gloating but it's
gold let's go it's good to go on this
one flashlight if i test it higher in
the nielsen ratings on that oh oh
you have no idea why
listen man i that's what i felt would be
adequate we've had this conversation you
know saying like when you you during
your tenure you know it i always felt it
was the energy that you brought to the
role and look are we going since we
being honest you know
my issue was when during because you had
all that great run but then i remember
they brought out and they did inside
xbox
and
i had a problem with it
because my thing was like it was so
personality
driven and i wanted more like just focus
on the game plan stuff but the only
times the only one of the few
personalities that i did like was you
you know and the energy that you brought
to it so i was just like you know
my question for you was one you know the
thought process behind the show because
it was very controversial some people
were like yo
why are they doing this and all the
people like yo this is not for you this
is a marketing thing it's very it's
still you know what i'm saying people
looking at magnifying glasses when that
is that xbox coming back we want to talk
[ __ ] yes so it's like yes it became this
thing it was a very polarizing thing
some people like that some people didn't
you know i'm saying so my question is
like what was the thought process
internally behind if you remember back
then and um do you think they bring it
back
i'm curious do you think i'll come back
yeah i'm curious but they always had a
struggle don't get mad at me oh uh see
the summer for it i'm like oh i can say
this it's nothing crazy
they've come out and said they've always
had to struggle with understanding that
i think larry's larger than life right
nelson is a brand i know that by himself
millions if not tens of millions of
dollars go through majornelson.com as
far as like purchases maybe not so much
anymore because he's been able to kind
of pull back from it but if you bring
larry on stage
that means there's a certain level of
pomp and circumstance true as expected
and true um graham not as much but still
jeff sure
so when it came to planning and
executing
the guy's new broadcast production got
you guys in gauss and tina coming from
tv like it was freaking gorgeous oh my
god yo the setup was amazing
my problem was the expectations that
that set right if you have an e3 stage
that cost thousands tens of thousands
maybe hundreds of thousands whatever it
costs i don't know the actual numbers on
it
um
people are going to expect
announcements you can't do that yeah
good point good for it and we knew that
too like we very much knew hey this is
running light this is running dry
i don't think people were
injured this is pretty tick-tock so i
don't think people were as willing to
let go of that long-form sort of format
yeah the beautiful format and have
something that's
not as polished more succinct that gives
off that community vibe and feel one of
the lessons that i always got taught
when you talk about that woman jen who
was my boss is she was like i don't care
about the video being neat and polished
like make it say its point we'll get
better for next time get it out so it's
topical right but it can be rough social
can be rough and i wish they would have
treated inside xbox more rough
because i think shining the beautiful
lights the beautiful stage that we
weren't allowed to walk on the xbox logo
and doing all that having larry having
phil all the time oh yeah that just
made people think it was going to be
something way more than it is that's a
good point it is and then it was
good the pro i always felt like the
problem with that is
you had a peep a lot of people in the pr
department trying to communicate to like
fans and
i never felt like
it's hard for
us to communicate with them and for them
to communicate with us because
besides marriage and else like a lot of
people don't even know who a lot of the
other people were and i felt like there
was
there wasn't a lot of spotlights on
games like you know cognito said like
and i've always felt like
inside xbox is a good
outlet for the stuff that they have and
always felt like they never showed it on
their stage right it was always
somewhere else and all it's it's just i
think inside xbox can work
but i do think it got to be ran
different yeah i just i agree i think
you know a little less personalities
faster pacing and get to the trailers
get to the games and have more of a
seamless transition that was my only
thing because it i think you nailed it
recari the production value was so good
that we almost maybe it was us as fans
expected like e3 level type
announcements at this show and maybe
obviously it wasn't targeted for that
but i think that's what the expectation
said so maybe if the format would say
but i had to ask you that because i was
very curious through that era but i did
want to transition because i know we're
running long but um
to now right so it's like
here and now senior you know i'm saying
community manager over at gamestop how's
that transition been for you in the new
role you know what i'm saying doing that
and then um just in general with
gamestop and like how you feel
they adapt right now in this day and age
and this time
hmm
let's see here what i'll get in your
community
nothing will get me in trouble i'm
trying to figure out because there's a
lot that happened between that first
inside xbox right now go break it down
get take us down real quick yeah if you
can
did i ever tell you the story about how
i quit inside xbox nope not another one
no um
so we talked about those first
this this is going to be a journey about
finding oneself
let's get it let's get it
inside xbox first couple of episodes
happen
and your boy was out here shucking and
jiving i don't know if you guys remember
but they had they had larry graham and
jeff delivering news and i was at the
social desk
literally reading responses from twitter
about what people were saying about the
show though i was the only person right
beside you and there's like a black desk
or something like that yeah i was that
big old surface table yes yes and um
yeah it was fun but they were like i was
like what are my lines they're like just
pull up a few things that are fun cheeky
you know have fun with it and i was like
y'all got me out here as old boy that
pulls people off the stage at the apollo
like
you're doing it i'm steve harvey and
kings of comedy i'm just working the
crowd so the actual acts come out i was
pissed i was upset and not because i
wanted to be them
more so that i thought i had to be them
you know i was like i feel like i'm you
know when i say sideshow bob it's not
that i'm the sideshow it's that
i don't know that
i was literally just clapping and
dancing and not doing anything of
substance of this or the show
of that year um
i you know i ran up and much like
running into you guys that pack somebody
said hey man what shoes you got on it
was a group of brothers and i was like
what what you mean and they're like come
on man we see you on inside xbox like we
know
you always wear a different pair of
shoes every episode like
you notice that huh oh yeah kick game
come on man they're like you're the only
one up there that gets up there in bs's
and doesn't have to be all stiff and
proper and i was like y'all like that
huh and it was in that moment where i
had to realize i was like oh i can be me
and not worry about being them and
having to be right and having to be
proper and respectful and deliver a
certain way um
so that's what kind of took off and i
did the stuff in 2017 and all of a
sudden i'm doing all these speaking
engagements and again and i'll blaze
through it just because yeah i know you
guys are short on time um
you know being myself not caring about
the athletes or the actors because i
realize they put on their pants one leg
at a time just like the rest of us
and then i get let let go for microsoft
in 2019.
not because i wasn't it wasn't for any
performance related issues which was
great because i still got my bonuses and
all that
but it was one of those realizations
where i was like
i did all this stuff and it didn't
matter in the end right you you do this
stuff and when it comes just business
and numbers that's all it means so why
wasn't i taking care of myself got you
um and i'm going to jamaica to do a
segment with usain bolt where the hell
was my camera i was worried about taking
care of popping xbox and i should have
brought my camera like myself yo this is
dope they're sending me to london
where's my camera right you know let me
let me stop i stopped caring about the
companies as much and it's almost like
this workforce shift now where people
jump jobs to move on and move up yeah
it was kind of one of those realization
moments where i was like i gave them 10
years damn near
and not that they just i don't think
they cast me aside okay but it was
definitely like
it can go away like like that game stops
pretty much like a creative differences
at that point so
it was
no it was just money it was just they
were shaving okay so think of there's
two waves there's marketing waves and
then there's always dev waves and when
dev waves are starting and you're
getting closer to release
and then you get past release well
that's when marketing is really ramping
up right right and then dev kind of goes
into other bits and devwave falls and
marketing takes over to make sure people
are buying and playing and then
it's different now with games as
continued services instead of just to
release and forget
i knew a layoff was coming and i was
working on xbox streaming with another
full-time employee who had been there
longer than me and i was like okay if
anybody gets cut it's going to be me
right i knew that i was well aware i
missed
a ton of layoffs but when it finally
came that the anger was just
and not even anger
the realization was that i tried so hard
to make it look like my focus was xbox
not that i was out there traveling the
world meeting the rock and usain and
ronda rousey and all this stuff i was
like i don't want people thinking i'm
having fun because then they're gonna
you know get mad at me for having fun
now i'm like uh hell no i'm having fun
i'm gonna bring everybody along the ride
with me as you should so as it gets to
gamestop as it pertains to them yeah be
very honest i just needed a job
i started 2019 off well excuse me i
started after i got laid off july 5th
2019. a month later i was on stage at
the gamestop expo with xbox so i was
hired by xbox to go to the gamestop uh
managers expo okay
and i'm on stage talking about xbox i
got paid a five digit sum for that and i
was like this hosting thing is it oh
host it is fire yeah i was like this is
what we gonna do this is what we gonna
do i know it was a you know a few day
package so don't think it was like that
crazy for one hour but whatever i was
like we're gonna host i've already got
the ends let's go and they're hiring me
we did the super bowl we did a couple
other things and i'm like yep this
hosting thing here we go and you know we
all know what happened march 2020 yeah
so i started hey 2020 was the greatest
quarter i've ever had in my life
was lit
but the worst year yeah
yeah so i started and i signed like 65
000 worth of contracts it's like we
taking over i'm bringing my cameras
march came in here
and everything stopped so you go
thankfully i was able to live for about
a year and a half
but it got to maya last year and i was
like hey
your boy needs a job and it just so
happened to be and we talk about all the
connections we've made over the years
guy justin calls me
hey what'd you think about working at
gamestop like you've been barking up
this tree for a while now to rewind
justin was the community manager on halo
and gears when i was the kid lying wait
stop
that's crazy
he doesn't like to be public like he's
not out there like that anymore on
twitter but i don't know if you remember
the name six okay but he did uh he did a
bunch of stuff with microsoft got laid
off from microsoft as well went to robot
he was working on orcs must die
um and yeah it's been at gamestop for
the past few years so it came full
circle and they've been trying to poach
me for a long time and so i was like i
mean the truth was i was like hey i'm
not telling him but whatever comes up
i'm going to take i was actually talking
to the xbox third-party hardware team
too and so there was still a chance at
that point they were still yeah i was
like whatever
i mean i had just started and i said
whatever first offer comes i'm taking it
because you're now in your game stop
gave me the title
so that i was like yeah we're going
there you go in there and and this is
like you said pandemic
it's rough out here you know what i'm
saying it was brutal and i went through
it myself i got laid off by one of my
xit companies went down and it was just
like yo what's the next move right like
what's the next move and you gotta i
know that feeling brother like that it
gets real you like yo something don't
pop soup
first time the 15th or the first comes
and nothing hits your account and you're
like oh
we're fine we're okay look at all this
money you got in here and i was like
yeah but when it's not going in yeah
it's coming out
that's actually what that layoff taught
me is i was like i no longer will i have
a singular source of revenue good point
like i need to figure out how to i don't
care if it's pennies on the dollar here
and thousands of dollars there and a
hundred here like i need to figure out
ways to keep checks coming in because i
didn't i was uncomfortable no i'm not
too much hustling yeah me and you the
same bro that's how i was saying it was
like you were not like completely dead
in the water but you know realistically
when there's nothing coming in and it's
slowly drained up if you don't start
moving and being proactive to do
something then it's going to get ugly
and you you stopped it before luckily
you know i'm saying you're blessed
you're able to get opportunity before it
got to that point but i respect that
story bro because it's like that's real
life you know saying a lot of people
don't understand it's real out here
we're smiling we're having fun and we're
getting a chance to do the things we do
but the gaming industry is a volatile
industry i tell people all the time like
it's tough so salute to you man i just
love to share the story of of the full
circle aspect you know what i'm saying
and now you're back out there host
you're about to do i would be in
you'll be at gcx i've seen but the other
big thing is i told them right when i
first started funny enough i told them i
don't want to be on camera and they were
like well you know there's going to be a
certain bit of on cameraness with being
a community manager and i said yeah
but
unless it's my job if you want that to
be my job just put it in my jd yeah like
xbox made me mad because they'd always
treat it like
like i should be thankful for it
like i wasn't just doing all this
marketing for them um but yeah and i
said number two i was like i still want
the freedom to go do my hosting on the
side okay okay i was like because i was
like you all will never be able to pay
me enough not that that's a bad thing
but yeah i just know my worth and if i
can go do that and they were like
my boss said he's like if you become
more famous we become more famous i was
like oh bet so yeah i get to do gcx
negotiation or fleek let's go all right
let's go i see you like you do gtx in a
couple weeks oh wait i didn't mean this
to know you said no you said it to the
contract bro
this is powerful stuff man powerful
stuff love the heated journeys like that
the real talk behind the journeys and i
appreciate that so much brother i was
going to transition to some to being
quite the final questions that we do
unless uh addict had a question or solve
that question before we move on to the
final stuff but um guess that oh let's
no no yeah well i don't know if you can
answer this or not but i know you know
in recent years everybody everybody sort
of valuing the
the end of the game stop what does that
mean you know oh my god you know what's
going to happen to that to that brand
and you as a person who's out there
having to talk about it and sort of
specifically connect with the community
that's going to either make or break
that that that that brand
has it been
it have you
had in your time there has it have you
seen it as being very transitional from
what it used to be
or is it is it kind of business as usual
from what we know of gamestop
you know we talked earlier before the
show started about not knowing
and it's not that i've tried to be
ignorant on it it's just that i don't
understand the business side of it i
will say it's not like gamestop had
shutdown plans right you know when i
think of the likes of circuit city what
else blockbuster all these things that
went away
they kind of just did yeah so i very
much live every day like it could
but i don't think there is a
clear delineated path to going away if
that makes sense until it's gone
because no business owner will ever
you know or a group of owners will ever
say hey we're probably going to be
shutting down here in about a year no
they're going to do everything they can
so that said gamestop the pitch that
they always gave me this guy justin
always gave me even a a year before i
started he was like we're doing fine
we're sitting on cash
stock craziness yeah it's just proof
that you know we don't know what's going
to happen in a year or two yeah but i do
know that before that they were talking
about the cash they had sitting on and
these transition changes and pandemic
messing stuff up so
i don't look at it and maybe this is the
horrible part as my forever home in the
sense that i thought microsoft would
like forever home and that went away
right so i look at it as what can i
learn in my ten years here now yeah
whether that be for one year three years
five years where are my growth
opportunities and where's my chance to
get better fantastic fantastic way of
looking at it and and one thing you
realize i mean i realize
in the industry is just that like like
you said like sometimes you got to take
advantage of the here and now and how
you can improve your skill set and what
you can get out of it and we're kind of
away from the days it's really rare this
time like to be with one company like a
lifer for something in this day it's
really hard like it's really like an
accomplishment and a lot of some luck as
well but yeah i hear your point on that
man it's very very valid points really
cool story definitely will transition
you to the question we asked
all the guests in the realm
sure i need more ricari's top five video
games or franchises
of all time
halo ce is definite favorite of all time
tony hawk pro skater
um and whether that's franchise or game
what else do i just pick up and play all
the time
goldeneye is still another one
best possibility of the game
yeah
right mm-hmm um what else we got in
there any generation nfl blitz oh first
nfl blitz reference okay hell yeah
and you know oddly enough
oh i want to say star fox or sonic
there's so many games that just have
different reasons for turning me on this
can evolve over time
yeah
whatever let's
what's it no super mario world world
okay yeah
the final one favorite
the thing to know about me is
i never think anything is good or bad
okay it's just it's
what can i glean from the experience and
what do i find myself having fun with
that's what it's about also when i
started working at xbox and i would have
to be on streams playing games to play
xpla i got opened up to a breadth of
games that i had no idea existed because
my little purview was about yay
so i'm here for whatever and i know
there's a lot that i've missed
um this is
yours has no weight like it's like i
guess if i got a pick this is yo this is
what it resonates for halo halo halos
the halo's number one of course got that
ce in their respect and favorite console
of all time and why
there was something that clicked for me
about the dreamcast
you didn't see this okay
um the 64. i mean it was the first one
that i really got to spend an unholy
amount of time with
got those demo discs it's the console on
which i first was introduced to tony
hawk
i had a ton of fun with nba or excuse me
nfl 2k
for some odd reason even in thinking of
the you know the virtual memory unit
yeah it's the vmu
yeah it's like i when i think of it it's
holding a special play like it that's
yeah that's what i'm thinking back to
classic classic console classic 64 is
close okay okay that's five of us a
little to the car each of the guys yeah
yeah i think we never we didn't touch on
this
maybe there's a reason for it so when we
talked about the sega love there was no
cause when you said you worked on
crimson dragon and kind of that that
promotion that's the spiritual successor
to like phrasal dragon here we go were
you a saturn any type of sega saturn in
your life or leading the white house
leading the witness
all i had was a sega and that's all not
necessarily we could afford but it's
just all we had like i couldn't
michael the same kid that had sega
channel ended up getting a saturn but we
just
i think
with my age my neighborhood all that we
weren't ready for discs yet okay okay we
weren't ready for discs okay um
not too rough i remember i remember the
price of them and all that and my dad
was like wow we can get these genesis
games for this month
so no i wasn't able to do that and i
think the genesis
you know the genesis came out when i was
13. you started to hit that 14 year old
you could legally work and i was working
i had money
yeah it became the first thing that i
could go do got you and really go do on
my own no doubt selena card is fires
fire let's get these topics going so
we're gonna get the super chats while
yeah we got the um the uh poll yeah we
got a couple real quick oh you already
got that okay cool yeah they're lined up
we got mad 410 member for 27 months
thank you sir good day lords appreciate
you brother
and we have splendiferous two dollars
super chat
savvy you know what you talking about
player sports talk sports talk
back then
and we got necromancer zale five dollar
super chat i missed those kb toys k
merchandise days running to the video
game section looking at sega nintendo
games felt more magical back then yes as
a kid you just that's
that's like that's like going to
disneyland
cedric h two dollars will be chat do
y'all remember the playstation pizza hut
demos ricardi mentioned this i don't
remember that me for me personally maybe
it's because i was you know i had a
modded playstation i'll say that yes
i don't remember too many of those
playstation uh demo this but i do
remember other demo this replacement
and we got chaosanti
salute to the lords and the great guests
loving the stories really hitting home
we miss seeing you on xbox streams lord
ricardo
absolutely
now we got dragon heart yobe tv
10 super chat what's up brother i'm
calling it now based on rumors the
achievement list popped up in january
february rumors said it was a june
release goldeneye
double 07 hd remaster will be announced
during the showcase if not take my knees
[Laughter]
or he put it out all on the line put it
on the line
we'll see that'd be nice what's that
yeah we're good all right last week's
poll resulted in the people have spoken
with the series s outside selling the
ps5 for one week in japan do you think
the series s generation of consoles will
outpace all other generation of xbox
consoles before it the winner of the
four-way ilp poll at 54 percent was i
don't care little man is outside in
these japanese streets and nintendo
switches next so they feeling very
bullish very very bullish coming in at
second place at 22 percent of the vote
but series s will surpass the xbox one
and og xbox but not 360. in third place
at a close 18 with series s generation
consoles will be the eventual leader of
all
previous xbox consoles in japan and in
last place only four percent of the vote
was series s will easily beat xbox one
in japan but not the og or 360 group
shout out to all the lords who
participated in the poll flame you got
to be rigging these votes i see you
doing something with the messi lord
every time he's always in there he's
rigging so i know you're doing something
flame i know you all just let you know
i'm on you shout out to my man one bad
mother pulling up from xbox eric can i
get a mic check sir
testing testing however
perfect yes yeah i see you i see you bro
salute to company look like we got jd
gaming right quick solve yeah
uh jd game of five dollars if we chat
recaro would you go back to xbox if
there was an opportunity yeah it depends
on the role see now i'm at the point
where
the role is right money is right depends
on what my freelance stuff is doing what
i'd be allowed to do um okay gamestop's
been very flexible with the creativity
externally
so yes
the answer is yes i have no bad blood i
would absolutely do it absolutely um
if they wanted to utilize the voice
talents i'd be like hey let's build that
in so when i say rewarded not like paid
right but like hey you get a good job on
your review because you did these things
that you said you would do oh yeah
respect respect you heard that xbox phil
fell back to call me here fell out we're
gonna make happen
i'm just joking anyway moving on so we
gotta get into these topics y'all so
soft man you're up man i mean actually i
think i'm bad alex here so addict's up
yeah um you want me to set it up
adequate you got this yeah all right
i'll set it up for you man this is a big
one um playstation says half of its
releases will be on pc and mobile by
2025 shout out to video games chronicle
and uh ps4 releases will be phased out
and speaking during a business briefing
jim ryan said it's looking to expand to
larger platforms in particular
committing to releasing at least 12 live
service games in the coming years he
also stated that on the company expects
half of its annual releases to be on pc
and mobile by 20 20 25. he said they've
already kind of had the execution of the
single-player game delivery but they
said that it's he said but it's
certainly the case that we have
restricted ourselves to a rather narrow
portion of the gaming market he said by
expanding the pc and mobile and it must
be said also to live services we have
the opportunity to move from a situation
of being present in a very narrow
segment of the overall gaming software
market to be present pretty much
everywhere so this one was kind of
making the waves addict this is your
topic what did you feel what did you
want to bring us to the realm
don't we got a video oh we got that you
know what we do we got a video so let's
see what's going on oh no what's going
on out here what could happen yes so i'm
not gonna be there this weekend but uh
it's gonna be a great show right so
my my topic that we all talking about
y'all talking about playstation and the
revenue this year from the pc
and i want to say you know thank you
for jim
for um putting nexus to work
and you know that's my heart nexus is my
heart oh my god uh they doing fantastic
work but i do want to say
that uh shout out to jim
because my my check came in for
supporting playstation so i'm able to
pick up my boat
yeah
yeah so i'm getting my yacht game
together we're going to be moving i'm
going to try to keep up with jim
but um yeah playstation revenue pc told
you i'm 97 right
everything is switching over games of
servers pc is happening nexus is getting
these games out there horizons don't get
there yo shout out to eternal getting
the sting we saw the steam database
it was ridiculous so what i got to say
and what y'all got to do is follow jim
dan's move and make sure you're staying
tuned it's crazy
100
bars
king catch y'all later oh
i love the fact
that right now
services
is in vogue y'all are getting down with
the program and um pc is something that
you're gonna support too shout out to
the team in blue we know how y'all do
y'all don't follow the league when it's
own green but as soon as we switch it
over to you that's how you do
boy
who's that special guest
we got the random king from the beach
cameo
[Laughter]
[Applause]
why you act like you got the boat for
the playstation you're ridiculous yeah
the rings on i heard the keys
[Laughter]
where are we at with this bro
it's just you know it says what we've
been saying for a while you know a lot
of these besides nintendo these platform
holders they're looking to make more
money
and
the best way to make more money is to
put your stuff on more platforms yes and
it's looking like you know
xbox was there first uh it does look
like playstation's following maybe not
as fast
because xbox they they just jump
straight out the out at the at the
airplane they're like everything's their
day one but it looks like playstation
slowly uh indoctrinating their fan base
to buying stuff on a pc
so it's an interesting thing because if
you look at it like they expect a way
more return off the pc market this yeah
coming up quarters
it was like almost quadruple pc what it
was
so like to me it's just like
if you expect that kind of increase in
your pc cells what you about to do sony
what's jim ryan about to do you know we
could start out with soft because soft
never goes better yeah let's all go for
the video after that
i mean jim this is the thing i've always
said this um
you know king king king axe like you
know
he he wants them to go away
but but but they're making all the right
moves right
it's something that that that that um
the cog has said it's like
there's no hubris here
they're acknowledging the changes in the
market
and they're doing what's necessary in
their own way
to adapt to that in a way that doesn't
scream hey you need a second job for
this console it's not that
so yeah they're being resistant to the
day and date and i get that the thing is
that if everything they have in place
works they're never gonna need to do
that right if these service games pop
let's say what however many service
games they want to have
if two of them are successful
right and if this mobile sort of
initiative is successful in any way
shape or form when i say mobile i mean i
don't know that we've seen what
nintendo's done in the mobile space
there's some money to be made i don't
know if a core mobile game is what
they're thinking about or just rather
cloud you know core games in the cloud
on mobile maybe that's what they mean by
that
but if all of this stuff hits in a real
way then it doesn't make him a liar when
he says we're going to continue with
these big triple a
you know uh super polished super high
production value experiences right it's
going to continue to happen because now
you have all of these other service
based things to support the development
of those games which are more and more
are super expensive and they're going to
continue to get more expensive and us as
fans we're not going to take
you know accept a drop in quality we're
not going to accept something that that
looks or feels lesser than the last of
us part two right we're not gonna accept
that anymore so he realizes that to keep
that all of this other stuff has to fall
into place right if it falls into place
i'm seeing that they will never i mean
we'll get closer to day and date on pc
we'll get to six months maybe we'll get
we'll get the six to ten months maybe
within a calendar year right
but i don't know that we ever get day
and date if all this stuff starts to
happen because they don't need to the
strength of the playstation name and the
straight playstation brand globally
is so strong that it like i said if this
stuff works
it's not gonna matter like it's not
gonna matter all this other stuff that
we're saying that they're gonna fall in
line with and we've been saying all
along they're going to fall in line and
that was with the assumption that they
were approaching the situation with
hubris and were resistant because no
this is the way we're going to do things
and no jim ryan says certain things that
made people assume they were going to do
stick to the status quo and you realize
that that is not it
so
this stuff again i got to give it to jim
ryan like
it's exciting because he understands
that the power of playstation is not in
the walled off garden it's not in just
the console space right it's everywhere
and when playstation is everywhere in a
real way
look out
look out be careful what you wish for
be careful
disagree i think there
there is a good chance they go day and
date with their pc games um
we can get to a b i got thoughts this is
a good this is a good discussion for it
let's get this going
okay here we go let me clarify yeah
peace pc makes sense pc does make sense
right because it's just an exp once they
consider pc fully an expansion of their
ecosystem and not some side thing yes i
mean
i think you see them drop something like
factions or just one game well that's
the thing the difference themselves
between that and six months
it would be stupid and that's the thing
right i'm meaning core games like that
their first party their single player
narrative experiences i think see
he's already lying about the fact that
those service based games aren't going
to come day and date to those it makes
no sense you need player bases and you
need player bases day one
it doesn't make sense that you wouldn't
put that game out on pc day and date so
i
you know i think i think he's lying
about that like that that's a beautiful
reality okay yeah yeah for sure so
mccorry man
where are we at with this you know we
see any you know they're making the
announcements they're
showing the success financially of how
they're doing you know with some of the
pc releases and now this commitment and
like the terms like you know narrow
marketing and expanding like what does
this mean to you when you hear sony uh
talk talk this talk about the other
markets
gaming is the biggest industry that's
out there all the others combined still
don't equal the revenue that gaming
brings in
so there's nothing wrong with opening
you know opening yourself up to a larger
ecosystem
i don't ever walk into a store and get
mad that
we'll go back 20 years let's go the
movie that i want to watch that's on vhs
is also on dvd
i i've never understood the gripe
um because i think consoles will always
live on in that
if i just want to plug in this box into
my tv and i know that it works with
minimal
things that i need to do i need the hdmi
cord we're good great i've got my crazy
pc set up but i have to go through
individual components to make sure
things are optimized there's a crowd for
that too but we're going to sell them
both but ricardo what about the thought
process that having it on a another
platform devalues your experience
because i was told that that but the
people that argue online
so you say the people that argue a lot
is a echo chamber and a small
representation of what gaming means is
that what we say
absolutely one of my favorite bits on ki
there was this uh feature that came out
called combo assist combo assist
basically hit the
you you didn't really have to focus on
the timing you just had to hit the
proper button in succession to pull off
your combo it kind of took the left
thumb stick out
all of our all of our super engaged core
audience said this is terrible
absolutely terrible you're cheapening my
experience i'm going to be losing
matches i shouldn't be and then we got
the data from our user research
analytics
yeah people that had combo assist on on
average played for like 30 to 40
engagement
wow so these decisions are made by data
and not just because people yelling on
twitter and being upset yeah yeah yeah
that's crazy
that's crazy
look i i don't understand why people get
upset you should be happy because you
expand that pool of potential players
pool of potential buyers all of a sudden
you get more content for games that live
on longer now are there trade-offs yeah
sure it's crazy to watch a market in
which games are released in a
less than optimal state but games are
also a yeah
all right you'll use ki again you guys
have no things not working right before
they ship ki is multiplayer online
multiplayer did not work and if you
remember how bad the xbox platform's uh
networking services were two weeks
before ship could you imagine not being
able to play the game that you're
supposed to be able to play against
players online yeah
anyway we we are in a world where games
come out
purposefully unreleased fortnite is
still in beta and i think there are
times that we're accepting of that times
where we're not but sometimes i feel
like we pick and choose when we're going
to be like it's tough to think of halo
as this live service game but it
definitely is that now but then i do
like a campaign and i'm like dang i wish
this one would have been done done and
i'd have my co-op and not have to wait
for it but anyway point being is that my
viewpoint on it all is right i still get
to play wherever and however i want to
play so i've got nothing to gripe about
oh safe okay so you're enjoying your
experience despite someone else okay
that's an interesting thought man i mean
this is really cool before i pass it to
the one man i wanted to ask you about
the live service component specifically
and the aggressiveness there we're
seeing we're seeing now he's saying what
12
live service game which is kind of kind
of new for sony like what do you feel is
it is it again a situation where you
think they may be looking at the trends
the data of the top games whether it be
free to play and and that kind of stuff
i want to get a part of that like what's
your thought when you hear them talk
about wanting to jump in that market
well games are no longer ship and forget
right we
you know street fighter was a live
service game though it was slower with
its service updates ki shipped something
like 40 something updates
even balance changes would make you a
live service game
so it doesn't always have to be call of
duty or fortnite type of live service i
think we as a consumer base just have to
shift how we think about game releases
and it used to be you got your game that
was it there might be a huge one-year
title update or a cu that came out
actually no yeah cu was when we started
shifting into the service type thing so
um
i think we
look at the
title of live service and think that
that means the game has to hit certain
metrics but that's not really it it's
more so everything is a service because
it's constantly updated via cu so i
think they can pull off 12 right just
what do we define as a live service
title fair enough fair enough
one bad mother thank you for coming
through the round brother always good to
see you guys having me kyle always
brother always been so like wait wait
yeah with this thing you know
playstation making the commitment more
to pc games and mobile and to their
audience as well as the 12 live service
games
well you first you were asking about uh
does this devalue the uh the ip i guess
that we could ask that question what do
we think is worth more you know fortnite
or got a war right one's uh one's a
double a game that was uh you know
failed at launch and you know relaunched
as a life you know the big live service
game for free
and uh you know the other is a really
well-known ip i think when people get
into the devaluing thing what they're
talking about is uh what's that value to
me when i get in twitter spaces and have
a console war
oh this is a selfish act this is not
about the the growing of the company
that they love is is it not about the
don't they want their company to grow do
they they profess is this not what it's
about this is all about the sport of
godfathers and we know this right we
know we know this has nothing to do with
the value of ips
um
yeah
you know the last few years we've heard
take two ea come out and say you know
they've they've talked about the revenue
and two-thirds of the revenue is just
the residual income that comes off of
existing games like only one-third
of their revenue is from those games
they're selling you know full price
retail games
and that's where you know that's where
the market's gone the last few years and
i think sony was smart you know when it
came to trying to sell a console
platform kind of staying in that lane
because that was their business and it
still is to a large extent today
but you know uh their publicly owned
company and what publicly owned
companies try to do is look for ways to
make more money because that's the only
way you're going to get investors
investing and so you know i to what
attic was saying earlier i agree i think
they're going to eventually come along
with everything you know right now it's
about you know uh branching out the pc
it's about getting uh trying to get into
that live service space to diversify
but uh at after that market gets
established with subscriptions
their their thing is to diversify and
grow because if they don't they're just
limited you know there's no point in
limiting yourself especially when you
have the ips they have right like crazy
that's the thing
i just got done watching you know uh
most of stranger things last couple days
than my daughter uh that's a
that's that's a show for what for 10 to
15 hours worth of of engagement they
invested what 200
that was 30 million an episode right
times nine episodes so you're talking
about 270 million just to get you in for
15 hours to hope that you've just
subscribed and forget about it right
and
i you know i when i when jim ryan was
talking last year he was talking about
him wanting to have a hundred million
people playing god of war somewhere down
the road so how are you gonna do that
like i i look at it so you got 20
million with with playstation consoles i
can see you getting a little bit more pc
but how are you going to get to those
numbers of engagement without continuing
to figure out uh other ways to reach to
reach the customers so yeah
yeah honestly uh i think they're going
i'm go i think they're going full full
out yeah i mean i i think the i'm sorry
eddie you was gonna say something
yeah i was gonna say you know i
definitely agree i think that
their prime example right now is they
know that
sure could they get more pc uh some more
console sales
yes and does it devalue
their exclusive games it only devalues
to pc gamers which is a small portion of
the people that have both
uh so
are you really losing much they're still
buying the game it's just not on the
platform it's on the cons it's on the pc
so it's just like i think that that
small percentage is definitely worth the
you know the investing into the pc
market because forever one person that
owns both a playstation 5 and a pc
there's probably six that don't own any
console on pc yeah and that's it
i'm sorry i think that's that's their
goal it's like look like we have a large
portion of the pc community that don't
own right a playstation
that's what we want and that's the thing
too like some of them would never own it
you know and these are people that are
new to the ecosystem and you're getting
them involved and now you're seeing
positive financial results so yeah you
don't want to like obviously you don't
want to narrow yourself but yeah i mean
i'll jump in real quick
you know welcome to the party
welcome to the party you know you've
always said this it's it's this is where
the industry is going and
and dudes have been in the chats
attacking us for for years you know when
we said this stuff it's a business like
the problem is gamers unfortunately
sometimes let there emotionally overtake
what makes business sense
and that's not how business works you
know i'm saying they're looking at
bottom line and looking at works and the
thing is just because you personally
don't like a game or don't like a
direction like these things are proven
with analytics and data and financial
you know that they're money makers and
the companies don't care about your
feelings they're going to do
what makes money so that's the thing
here we we're finally here welcome
this is where it's going and um i just
thought it was interesting now the only
thing i find funny was just like all
this moral grandstanding and
purist talk and you know what he values
my thing and all this like look i get it
all you can like what you like but try
to shame other groups for their stuff
going on multiple platforms and all this
stuff
now look who's mimicking who
let's be honest right as far as models
or certain things so that's that's the
thing just read the room see where it's
going
and jim ryan is literally saying it he's
outright saying hey the console market
is not enough you know what i'm saying
this is not something just to stay in
that box and he wants to expand it you
know now with the day and day stuff the
only thing i push back a little bit on
yourself because i see where you're
going i know you're going and this model
way they do it makes sense right you
drop it you have it exclusive as far as
the triple a stuff and then maybe you
know what it'd be six months a year you
go pc and then maybe after that six
months a year maybe you go into ps
playstation premium but i will say if
they're gonna be aggressive this is my
thought process if they're gonna be
aggressive with 12 live service games to
me it's their it's to their their
benefit to make those day and date in in
a service because you want
more engagement that's just me so i'm
curious
that's what that's what alex said and i
agree i didn't elaborate on that when i
spoke on it it's just that that those
are the ones that to me make no sense
not to do right day and day to me it's
like like i look at something like
factions right
and it's like look about how much
engagement you can get
if you got this last of us multi-player
component everybody can get in and day
one and then you know you could sneak a
little monkey transaction model whatever
it is you want to do sleep you get
i do feel like that mentality
to you know it's okay for us to put
these type of games on this platform day
one is what's eventually going to open
up the door to bringing all the to the
platform
it's a possibility and i will say if
they see that and then that's why to me
the bungie acquisition was the key one
to watch because they
specifically said we want use them to
help us carve out our multiplayer live
service ecosystem because of the
experience bungie has and that was it
because people like oh i don't get the
deal they don't get destiny exclusive
why did they do that it's not about that
it's the long-term goal how they want to
utilize budget because they admit jim
ryan admitted we're good at the
single-player native experience as i
just won but where we're deficient is is
this multi-player live service thing and
to me that's the sign of intelligence
knowing what you deficient in and trying
to improve it so don't address it
let's be real here uh you know sony's
not dumb they don't see the amount of
pla of the amount of studios that
microsoft owns they don't
they know
the output that they can deliver now
sure
it's subjective on if the games are good
or not we ain't seen a lot of them but
they they know that unless they start to
do something to
to clear that gap on studios being built
versus studios and games they can make
they know that sooner or later they'll
just they'll get overthrown by content
so that's why you see them willing to
make deals with people like bungie
that's like look like sure we we we'll
be able to use utilize
the you know the destiny name when it
comes to tv shows and stuff but in terms
of games you know they they really did
that just so they ca they want to come
out in this
in this uh you know regardless if it's
free to play or some type of games
disservice
they want to come out in these streets
already an amateur and they need someone
like bungie to help them do that yeah i
think the budgie moves and shot the king
the nexus move showed me
the the commitment to it but that's
that's pretty much why i got unless
anybody if i got anything else we could
move on so
i was just going to say i i do think
some of the things you're mentioning
about why it's it's important to put
multiplayer out there is why they're
going to put single player as well
because there is a zeitgeist right you
like there is like uh studies about like
that halo effect when you when you get a
lot of people talking about something
all that all of a sudden at one time uh
it actually drives the mind share which
it was just like free marketing right
like that's how we're seeing the game
pass effect help sales for a lot of
games and when when you kind of like do
the drip feed of like hey we're gonna
we're gonna put it on the console here
and then we're gonna wait six months and
and try to maximize you know get the cut
we want our cake and eat it too but then
you end up shortchanging your your your
content that way because there's just
you're just going to get less like geist
a lot of times those subsequent releases
aren't going to get uh the traction
right so like something like returnal
for example you know who knows like
maybe that would have been more popular
on pc which would have actually helped
drive more playstation sales
in addition to the pc one so that's just
something else i don't think they have
the infrastructure today to do that but
long term i think that's probably uh a
realistic expectation definitely a
possibility we just got to monitor it
man good good point so let's start with
the super chats we move on to the next
topic yep we got a few here hold on one
second
uh let me see
one away dragon's tv
super chat let's go brother what's good
my brother's recari looks good looks
canon r5c pre-ordered is that what
you're using there bro that's that's
expensive that's bougie camera talk yeah
oh he went to go get it oh
look you know so
it was one the red button gives it away
so when i was walking around taxis and
people saw this they were like oh
excuse me yeah pretty much there you're
in high definition so we got it we got
to chopping it up about the r5 r5c
lenses and all that i picked up the uh
24 to 70. um but yeah we've had a lot of
time in the media room talking about
talking about what we should and
shouldn't do and having fun i haven't
got the mic
but yeah anyway shout out to one away
dragon man that big kids are about
quality content
and the fun part was the reason why all
of this came about is because we walked
in front of one of his shots
no joke you're sorry to interrupt me no
you're good i was doing the interview in
the devolver digital booth and we were
trying to sneak out and again not a
little dude yeah and we didn't see the
camera and we just kind of ducked by and
we just here
yeah you know thanks for uh video
bombing me and i was like oh
yeah what a way what's saying he's
saying live thanks for being with me bro
yeah like because he was interviewing
back here talking to him so i'm like
cool this must be an audio thing right i
don't see the camera 10 feet this way
i'll walk through this and it's me my
buddy curtis curtis is like six three
four hundred yeah big boy
so yeah i see him upstairs and um
i got the mask on and king's there you
guys are all there and uh i said hey man
i just wanted to let you know my bad for
video
what killed me is that nobody said hey
it's cool
and king goes pull down your ass real
quick i was like what
he's like you pull it out of your mouth
like what the hell's wrong with you i
ain't going down my master ain't
that's vintage kid video bomb somebody
now i'm on the podcast there you go
yo classic moment salute away salute to
king man we had so much fun with pax
east it was good seeing everybody in the
element working moving and shaking you
know saying that was true the funny the
funny thing is when i was we got in the
media room and ricardo came back and
while recording come here he's like
we're gonna find a date right now oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we had a big happen
salute no doubt so what else we got and
we got ko3 black truth 10 dollar super
chat it's only right that we have a king
cameo yeah king could not you know yeah
they have a little something yeah a
couple bars in the top shout out to
attic for making that happen
then we got flame 2 super chat solved
come on
jimmy wouldn't lie to us hashtag
generations
bessie there we have tony bryant ten
dollars with chat great show today happy
to be here live shout out to ricardi for
my for my brother for driving 45 minutes
just to call me out for cheating and
kangaroo featuring the baseball that she
gets late
i literally got away with it for a
decade that's horrible
[Music]
we got jd gamer 20 chat halo 5 made more
money than the last of us because it's
service based xbox's lead in this area
has a lot to do with the early work that
bungie did with xbox on networking and
games on a console uh sony will benefit
from that now yeah that is true they 100
will yes
and we have jd gamer again 10 super chat
according to sony and it's probably the
same with xbox subscriptions um are
great but people into your ecosystem and
selling them add-ons
like skins etc is where the money is
really at so panel who wins this
interesting what's this gonna be yeah
again you have to i think
the i there's a sort of set it and
forget it thing where people just have
the subscriptions and and forget about
them is one thing but yeah you got to
keep people engaged if you if the live
service game is popping and they you
know and you're selling skins and stuff
like that that's what's going to grow
your game that's what people want people
want to be able to
to sort of you know customize their
experience as as they see fit so
it's gonna be interesting it's gonna be
interesting yes sir what else we got
uh let's see we got a couple more that
caught jumped in here give me one second
uh
our geek shiny ten dollar super chat one
bad mother in the house no doubt let's
get iop into the halo cgn sorry you need
to help out the weekly xbox podcast they
need the energy bro larry and jeff are
okay but you could make it more fun
loves the bag is right you gotta make
sure the bag is right there you go
exactly right you gotta be breath
strokes for different folks man they
they they like to do they prim and
proper i can't come interrupt that
shoot to the legends though salute to
them then we have jd gamer 10 chat panel
with so many single player only devs
trying their hand at multiplayer and
service based games and acquisitions all
about what are the chances platinumgames
gets picked up by microsoft and given
some multiplayer help
i feel like if anyone's picking a
platinum game today could be mike
yeah i don't know
we'll see retweet scale bound real quick
yeah real quick
wait on that jim ryan one though i want
to say one thing let's go this is the
one bit y'all say he would never lie to
you and we talked about him possibly
lying
hey there are things that are signed
things that are unsigned and it becomes
very difficult to navigate waters when
you know there are plans that may or may
not see the light of day or development
changes that happen that change the
entire shape of your landscape quickly
good point so i would say not to not
listen to people like phil or him but
they probably are telling you the truth
right now
what's going on right now
yeah absolutely absolutely and they
can't say one way or the other because
it might not happen it might change
that's why you see them not wanting to
make like definite
over-committed statements absolutely at
all they always keep it open when did
well you could take this ten different
ways
i'm training man it's a training that
meet that men
everything
yes sir we're caught up all right so
this i think is me this i thought was
interesting you know what i'm saying so
it looks like a new book um the oh
actually not that new it was published
uh 2021 um titled the ultimate history
of video games volume 2 that reveals
xbox turn down marvel exclusivity offer
so it looks like yeah this was a big
thing and apparently uh marvel execs
looking to reinvigorate video game ips
to rival batman arkham had approached
both microsoft and sony around the same
time and according to the vice the then
vice president of marvel games jay ong
he pinged both sides both xbox and
playstation and said we don't have any
big console deals with anyone right now
what would you like to do and at the
time it looks like microsoft's strategy
was to focus on their ip so they passed
and then the deal as as we know now goes
down in history as far as sony taking
the offer with the sound yet games i
believe they call the people involved
also was adam boyce some legends in the
game there so this was making the rounds
this week it's not exactly new
information because it's been out but at
the same time it was kind of like well
wow like
xbox could have had spider-man right you
know and and the whole deal there so
let's let's get this to the table let's
start with you ricardi um what's your
you know you around during the xbox one
generation and everything going on with
it so what's your thought process when
you hear something like this did you
think microsoft made the right call wait
where you at with this
you can never focus on what is i'm sorry
i'm gonna keep this short but sony had
the chance to buy all of marvel's
properties
and films and whatnot and they said no
just give a spider-man and i'm not
talking gaming i'm talking the whole
universe like movies and all that way
before anyway we can't focus on what
would have happened should you have done
that because if we all had hit
you know that dot com boom in 99 2000 we
wouldn't be sitting here talking about
this now and if we all have bitcoin in
2008
so whatever
they missed and maybe they made the
right moves for themselves maybe they
didn't i don't know what their business
priorities were
here we are fair enough if we're the
fifth we'd be drunk um
opm where are you at with this man
marvel spiderman where you at
yeah i mean i
i recaro is really kind of on to on to
something
but but you know the one thing though
too is like people if you look back to
see where
uh like superhero ips were at the time
outside of the batman games by
rocksteady
which outside of rock city nobody really
was able to hit those right and rock
said he didn't just leverage a batman ip
because uh it wasn't just they didn't
sell that game as well as they did just
because it was batman because we if we
remember there was a lot of bad batman
games leading up to that right like
expectations were low uh they came out
with a great game that happened to have
the batman license you know they they
kind of
set the bar when it comes to what we
expect for certain types of combat now
right like there's a reason why people
refer to the batman combat and you know
it was the same with spider-man if you
look at like the top sales going back to
like the ips that have sold the most in
gaming going back really throughout all
of history like there's only two
superhero ips that end up really high up
there it's spider-man and batman and
most of spider-man sales have happened
since insomniac so
you know like
sony was really smart to partner they've
made a great move uh partnering
insomniac was spider-man it was a match
made in heaven they had you know they
they hit a it was a perfect storm uh if
microsoft would have bought that back
under the myerson era
you know who knows what we got we might
have got spider-man looking like
crackdown
yo
you all want the avengers spiderman with
the zumba shooting you don't want that
you ain't want that
oh man
we might not be like
talking about this microsoft made a
superhero does anybody need a superhero
ip right so
so it's a you know
and and i think even their focus today
it's really
the focus should just be on making great
games and if you can find a way to
partner uh a great studio with an ip
that makes sense
you know like i remember there um
you know there was some talk before with
uh uh
the the head of uh ferguson was talking
about you know um
you know uh
what was his captain america right like
like if he had some great idea you had
somebody like that leading a studio that
really had their stuff together and they
had a great idea for an ip go ahead and
do it but you know like trying to force
that issue if you don't have the studios
if you don't have the passion there to
me you're just better off going and
trying to create something
something else that that does play to
the strength so great for sony uh in in
spider-man fans that that ended up
happening yes uh
but yeah i don't i don't i think that's
that world with meyer said i
thank god thank god
where you at man superhero games uh
microsoft potentially not only spiderman
could have any of their pick
of exclusive they went away from
activision with a spice i've got to
mention that activision's like yeah you
go do that you go find your unicorn
after leaving us
marvel what you think
what's funny is it's like
i understand i'm more a little bit
frustrated with microsoft over couture
that i mean
because i feel like
that is
a game that was probably gonna do well
unless you drop the ball completely like
i don't i don't i don't know obviously
we don't know what the logistics behind
that is but it's just like that
particular one it's like man cortora was
on the original xbox one of like the key
components that helped the xbox do good
back then and and to me that's the one
i'm frustrated with but like when it
comes to spider-man
that was a point of time where you know
microsoft didn't know what they wanted
to do with the xbox brand that was a
point of time where they they literally
just out of the
of the the xbox one fiasco like it
literally like they they were barely
breathing from the launch of the xbox
one so
and then like you even just like because
obviously there's a lot of rumors that
you know they were shopping around who
who might be interested in buying xbox
back then now if that's true
why would you go
and
sign a couple hundred million dollar
deal when you don't even know what you
want to do with the brand at that point
so it's just like it like look
in hindsight
yes they should have done it right but
it's not life is in hindsight like you
don't have a magical little portal that
could just that you could just relive
moments like they
at the end of the day the best thing
happened with that brand insomniac
uh because we don't i i'm more about
who's making the game not whether or not
what platforms make in the game and the
best developer got a hold of that at
that time we got to remember that's
before they bought anything in 2018
they had no one to make it to this day
you can argue that microsoft still don't
have no one to make a comic book hero
type of game so it's like what do people
expect them to do like so you i'd rather
go
the path that led to a better brand than
the path that led to
question marks right
if they would have got it we don't know
what will happen but then sonic
had experience making you know uh the
the type of ratchet and clank games that
led to the sunset overdrive and i feel
like that sunset overdrive template is
what they use to make spiderman well
said
it's just like
i get it like i said
be upset if you want i don't know what
to tell you like
like the better studio got the game
that's what should matter at the end of
the day because because of spider-man we
might get better comic book heroes
if if we got a bad spider much i'm not
saying microsoft couldn't have made i'm
pretty sure if they got it they could
they probably would have outsourced that
but that that is a that's a worm by
itself like they outsource this to
insomniac but
sony was probably shopping them anyway
they probably knew they were going to
own them in a couple years anyway so
it's just like
if they did outsource them in the game
and they outsourced into a studio that
wasn't insomniac and it turned out bad
for all we know that would have been a
domino effect that led to no more comic
book heroes being made because
it was like look every time we invested
in spider-man we have like one good game
from from activision we're not going to
continue to
to uh to put bets on this
people gotta remember too like look
spider-man's always been popular but the
mcu is what really put spider-man in the
main spain street like as far as the
movies and stuff
this decision was made before
spider-man was introduced into the mcu
right
it was before civil war that's true
now that doesn't mean that spider-man's
like it's always been an important brand
but i will say that then putting it into
those movies where every year it's
getting more and more popular
that is part of the things that led to
you know spider-man being so successful
now and at that time
the only thing you really had to go off
of is some games activision
let's be real like like obm said the
history of superhero games to that point
at that point weren't really great and a
lot of those was those bad movie tie-in
games sometimes and stuff like that so i
feel i feel what you got i feel you
going with that and not to mention at
that time even until now
we don't have a whole lot of like
like comic book tv movie
like annotations to games that actually
were successful
like we have batman
we have spider-man like oh that's all
and before spider-man we only had batman
yeah shout out to them shout out to
you're a batman arkham guy you know when
you hear this news where you at with
this
i mean you guys hit it out of the park
uh you know hindsight is 2020 right and
you can you know you can always talk
about what ifs but the fact of the
matter is that the state of the mcu what
meant there was no mcu um at that time
isn't what it is now and just
when you think about it it's it made
sense it made sense i think i think what
bothers me a little bit about it though
is just to interrupt you real quick
since they own the movie rights i'm sure
marvel had been trying to hit them up
for years before that they probably knew
the direction that the mcu was gonna go
right they probably had an idea what
they were gonna obviously gonna had an
idea what they were gonna do but to me
it just one thing that bothers me and
again again i don't know the
logistics behind you know why they
decided not to but the fact that they
they they saw the quality level you can
reach with the arkham games and kind of
said no we don't want to do that we want
to do our own thing right
to me it's like you know i don't know
there was no one there that
no one there said hey let's take one of
these characters and really make this
character our own and do something great
with it to me the idea that that
that sort of got shot down bothers me a
little bit but whatever secondly
is when you look at the reason why they
decided to go the other way their own ip
when you look at what they've released
of
of real substance since 2014 until now
you know you've had great games in in
their you know
burgers fries and shake series like halo
forza uh and gears they've had great
games there but
did they really have substantial new
first party ip that's come out and made
a you know they have state of decay
which wasn't theirs at the time right um
stuff like that like you know you have
ori things like that but at the end of
the day
what kind of strides have they really
made in their first party up until now
from 2014
so it's like there were a lot of
missteps again and like ricardi said
before you just don't know what's going
to happen how things are going to shift
and change
so i know just making like decisions
like that solve how like it for all you
know and this is most likely what
happened let's say sony did buy the
entire mcu universe and then guess what
they don't approve half the [ __ ] that
they did yeah that's for sure because
sometimes i don't have an mcu because
sony bought the whole thing and you hit
it on the nose when you said like
insomniac is the perfect studio to get a
spider-man game um even before sunset
overdrive their sort of their dna was in
that sort of kinetic sort of gameplay
and so it to me
it again
i think it didn't fall into place that
way and hindsight is always 20 20 but
again uh
wha to me what's what's a little hurtful
is just the fact that it's like damn
yeah they didn't really
they could have had it they could have
things that they've done since
kind of don't justify the fact they
didn't take it
i'll jump in
unless you finish i'm sorry i'll jump no
that's it so i mean today's a new day
obviously you know next week we'll find
out what some of that future looks like
hopefully yeah um yeah that's it i mean
you guys not pretty much too much i
could add here i mean same thing i mean
my initial feeling will still be
disappointment when i hear something
like that because they had the
opportunity of course i'm
i'm hashtag just one with with this
stuff y'all know me you know say i love
my you know cinematic narrative third
party exclusive and i'm a superhero mcu
geek you know fanboy whatever you want
to call me so
you know it does bother me that it was
turned down but then you know common
sense and now looking back again with
the hindsight stuff they really weren't
in position to make anything in my
opinion probably quality with it unless
the only thing i have to find was
interesting
was the relationship with insomniac at
the time though because insomniac was
working with microsoft you know they had
it they weren't under sony's you know
banner state so to speak so
theoretically i know this is the lotta
pie in the sky
theoretically they could have the same
game
if they someone made the decision to
give it to a zombie
yeah but yeah i know that's if and with
i i know i know i'm with you guys okay i
do think that
sony probably had the better
relationship with them to negotiate
something like that now i will say it's
arguably that you know you wouldn't have
the same spider-man without microsoft
helping them make sunset overdrive
because i felt like the motion system in
that game was
used to make the motion system for
spider-man it's like it's like a domino
thing like i said like because microsoft
went out and worked with someone like
insomniac gave them the uh the the ip
that was the reason that they worked and
they made sunset overdrive resulted in
years later than making spiders yeah
absolutely and all i'm saying
it happened for a reason i'm glad it
went to sony and we got the game we got
because yeah
at the end of the day it was the perfect
marriage you know shout out to adam boys
and them you know
they saw the execs and then the movie
influence and stuff like that with what
attic is talking about and you know to
me xbox at that time the main problem
was they didn't have ownership and they
didn't have enough studios you know what
i'm saying yeah they'd have budget and
like you said obm like you know we
talked about the terry myerson's phil
just started and he
at this point he wasn't in pocket in my
opinion with satya where there's a
commitment from microsoft to xbox at
that time at that time people like yo
are they even
going to be in this long term are they
going to commit to gaming that was the
question so to me it's not until they
admitted to that and then
yes they came out and said at that time
they weren't even sure they wanted to
stay in gaming they didn't thank you
satay even said like we're not going to
stay in this if we can't find a way to
lead right yeah it wasn't until
late 2017 is when you know phil got his
that's when he really became the fill
that we kind of know
now he's even grown since then but he
started to get some some sort of command
of the gaming and the budgets and things
like that so yeah i mean i think
everybody has everybody who's been on
xbox has a right to be very frustrated
with all the things that were happening
right up into that point because they
weren't investing right like it was i
remember after 2017 e3 like we were
like yo what's going on yeah yeah we're
all ranchers and and then you look back
at it obvious not to cut you it's just
that
they
they got they just didn't have ownership
a lot of these ips and the titanfalls
and the sunset and like it's all someone
else's and you can't control the ip even
i'm still mad about rise son of rome
don't get me started but anyway
i think that might be
a reason i'm okay with it because if you
deal with a spider-man you have to deal
with licensing every couple yeah
a studio to make that game let's be real
they didn't own any studio to make
something like that so they have to deal
with someone that can at any time after
the contracts might be like we good and
walk away now we'll say this
microsoft now though
if this opportunity comes across your
plate i don't want to hear about this in
the book that you turn this
like i said i'm just going to keep it a
buck ricardi i'm just saying
all i'm gonna say too is that it it
takes a long time to right the ship of
that
stature that size and so
yeah were they invested maybe not as
much as they should have been but they
didn't have this in their playbook
preach from a leadership perspective
from a tactical perspective strategical
whatever it was they came out with the
promise of you know the drm stuff and
all these things it's funny that we're
kind of at the point now but everybody
was woofing about it
eight years ago
so they had to start from the top
get rid of stuff there and you know it's
the hardest part about being behind the
scenes and seeing what happens is you
have to let contracts play their course
yes so people get upset
about things that aren't happening like
you know all these acquisitions and
people are wondering where the games and
i'm like we're probably not going to see
them for like four or five more years
because they're already working on
something right then they got acquired
they're going to finish that and then
they're free to do something new right
um right the time it takes to get from
where you're headed after you've spun up
tens of thousands of
you know employees in a singular
direction to move one it's a testimony
and a credit to phil and satya and
whoever else say that you were able to
make able to make these incremental
changes but it's still happening yeah so
while i am frustrated i you know i'm
fully like all right well
we'll be there someday yeah no you're
absolutely right and that's the reality
of the business and that's things that
people don't want to hear and they just
want to throw to you know put the tiki
torches up throw tomatoes and i get it
but that's the reality of the business
and i'm with you man but that's what it
pretty much i got sorry to chat last
topic to get about here yeah we got just
one more super chat jb gamer 5 super
chat let's be honest in 2014 xbox turned
down a very different mcu than the one
we have today there was no way to
predict the ultimate success of the ipc
that is true that is true they got one
from the dragon heart the homie yobe oh
we got another one back home i got him
um
shout out to dragonheart yobe tv file
super chat he said questions for the
panel if you're
if you had your own gaming company what
type of game would you make and how
would you make it stand out ricardo we
we missed the super chat we gotta fight
off super shot from dj orris oh stuck at
work just wanted to pop in and say some
love and hey besties
hashtag leg day
hey bestie yeah oh my god i gotta hit
that i gotta hit that this week so yeah
salute to him see you in gcx fool i'll
see you what's up brother no doubt we
caught up and then we got dragonheart
yobe's question so if we had our own
um gaming company what type of game
would you make how did you make it stand
out ricardi
just like publicizing games i don't want
i don't want to
make my own game in working in games
i've realized how unintelligent and how
uncreative i can but i could
wow that's uh that's one to come up on a
you know what i'm just going to say we
need more mass effect type games yes i
think that i i played i think i told you
i played that for the first time when
that was re the two and three for the
first time when i was released last year
and there was nothing else like that in
the last 10 years i don't think so uh we
need more of that absolutely what you're
making
um
probably
uh some type of like x-com style game
let's go okay okay probably like with
final fantasy characters oh there we go
tactics let's go i already see where
you're at soft what you're making
i'm making an iron lord side scrolling
oh let's get the background i'll make
this that's what i'm making make sure my
attributes are lit our bag make sure i
want the highest strength
there you go i mean i i think the
highest thing would be yeah yeah yeah
come on i'll be kick i gotta act you
don't say you could give him power but
just you know yeah yeah
[Laughter]
exactly exactly
yeah for me i just want some superhero
foolishness i don't know silver surfing
game is a dream game for me i don't know
how you do it because flying in video
games is damn near impossible to
replicate for design standpoint usually
breaks games but uh hey maybe a side
scroller shoot or something i don't know
but anyway that's what i got and then we
got what's it doofy you want to get the
light
yeah we got doovey hold on
king is the vendor who slanders your
choices
[Laughter]
we got doobie two dollars if we chat 500
in chat hit the like
every time you hit the like button you
save children so please hit the like
button
for the kids puppy every time you hit
the like button come on for the puppies
and stuff hit the like all right last
one and then we definitely had to get
out of here solve this is you
our favorite television brand
king's favorite television brand out
here leaking thing
so uh the king's heart tc giggs heart
tcl television
so earlier in the week they had a press
conference in poland i guess where they
were talking about their new
technologies and they were talking about
uh apparently how that's going to
integrate with the apparently upcoming
consoles
that look to be
mid-cycle sort of refreshes like we had
last generation with the uh the xbox one
x and the x and the ps4 pro
um and they sort of leaked out
information about what those consoles
could possibly do have under the hood uh
they're talking about anywhere from uh
8k output to 120 fps sort of more
standard so i guess they're going to
have more juice under the box they also
sort of leaked um radeon's next-gen
graphics card which is the 7700 xt uh
they talked about that with kind of more
certainty so
that seems like it's definitely what
that is
um so yeah
so
i don't know for me personally when i
heard this
it makes a whole hell of a lot of sense
consider when you take into
consideration the pandemic right for me
uh before 2020 i would have assumed that
this was going to be a normal more of a
normal cycle in terms of consoles that
we would see you know five or six years
of this console cycle and we're going to
jump to the next one after the pandemic
obviously we're you know looking now
playstation is still difficult to find
uh series x's are still somewhat
difficult to find and the s is out there
even you know we've come to the point
where uh even the switch is
this you're saying they they expect to
sell less consoles because again
everything is just slow in terms of
manufacturing and chips and things like
things of that nature so
um this makes a whole lot of sense that
we're going to get uh sort of mid gen
refresh which extends this generation
possibly to eight nine years whatever
the case may be
um so it's interesting it's interesting
and again it's something that i would
not have expected before 2020 but this
is where we're at i think this is true
um so what do you guys think is this are
you pissed off do you care do you want
more power and the things they're
talking about
it's funny because you talk about 8k
output and stuff like that
i mean when you think about a a 30 90
uh rtx card it's still not hitting that
right it's still not hitting that at the
outputs that we're talking about
yeah ak-60 um but again
another thing that we talked about shout
out to jason ronald in the times that
he's been on the show
we've talked about that this is really
the first generation when you hear about
the stuff that's under the hood in these
machines the secret sauce if you will
this is really the first time that a lot
of that technology feels real and
attainable and we've seen
real examples of that stuff at at work
at play so it
it stands to reason that these consoles
will make better use of those things
that we've been hearing since the start
of this generation and maybe make those
things truly a reality so if you talk
about you know amd's fidelity fx
whatever you know super sampling and
stuff like that 2.0 and you know how how
that can get us closer to that 8k sort
of resolution those tvs that you know
pretty much nobody has
um
so performance wise i think this there
are things in place that can make these
performance numbers a reality in a way
that i don't think was ever true in past
generations so we could yeah this is
stuff that could be potentially
interesting but could potentially sort
of piss people off
in terms of like hey i just bought this
console i wasn't able to get it day one
i got it you know two years into the
cycle and now you're talking about in a
year or two you're bringing out
something new right um obviously on the
chipset side if these are smaller chips
the yield you're going to be getting on
these chips as opposed to what we're
using now will be will be will be bigger
just because the chips are smaller
you'll be able to get
a lot more from one wafer so there's a
lot of reasons why this makes sense
i just don't know how the fans are going
to feel about it in the long term once
they actually announce this stuff so
what do you guys think no doubt let's
get uh let's get we'll be up first wait
where are you at with this tcl leaking
what's up
well at first i'm waiting for the king
video
we should have asked for this
[ __ ]
i'm not doing this one i just couldn't
hit that man too many times on vacation
not on the water yeah
i'm gonna try to guess what king was
gonna first say first he'd tell you not
to not to trust those tci trust their
leagues
don't don't pick your tv up off the
floor
dudes
can't trust them
uh we know how we know how reliable tcl
dudes are with the gaming league so
we're just going to kind of start there
but
yeah you know like they're like uh when
it comes to like just half jenna the the
[ __ ] upgrades and things like that
the thing you already mentioned it the
the fact that the tools are still
evolving like this is an interesting
generation compared to less where i
think they were able to
at least from a game design standpoint
were able to kind of hit that that top a
lot faster you know games got prettier
as we went along but there's a lot more
going on this generation with like
machine learning and like these these
these uh
consoles being more capable of things
like that to help with uh game
development and then you start thinking
about like the the extra
benefits you get with the cpus and the
uh
and the the throughput and things like
that so you're going to start to see
more game design evolution from there so
there's a i think there's going to be
it's going to be a longer period of time
you add in the pandemic to that it's
going to be a longer period of time for
them to really take advantage of the
what's in front of them today
and then when you go back to last
generation when they were talking about
the mid gen refreshes and why they did
it i think for microsoft and sony is
maybe slightly different microsoft
needed to get out from under the i think
the the branding that they got with the
power uh with the original xbox one but
sony came out and said hey the reason
we're doing this is because we don't
want to lose people over to the pc that
whole pc migration the fact that these
you know the fact that the hardware came
out and it was kind of
it wasn't
it wasn't that great to begin with for
either of them
being honest with jaguar cpu oh yeah
trying to get them frames
and then you look at the gap between the
the cost of pc of going from uh console
to pc was smaller uh at that time than
it is today now you got all these uh you
know not now not only are the consoles
more difficult to buy
but pc parts are harder to get and
they're a lot more expensive because you
got all these crypto miners and i don't
totally understand that but you know
there's people that are buying these and
by the boatload and it's driving up
those costs so i think it's just there's
not as much concern there it's going to
be longer for them to max maximize it
and then you know we have this other x
factor which is i think stillwell
actually talked about this on your guys
show a couple years ago he talked about
like that like you know leveraging cloud
processing like more hybrid type of
experiences we'll probably start to
define this generation and so
there's so much i guess room for growth
in terms of game design in terms of
tools for development
on top of the fact that we're already
delayed because of the chips
so it makes like this if they did have
it on on the docket at one point it
wouldn't have surprised me but uh
you know like just a plan in case but i
i'd be surprised if if really anybody
goes through with that at this point
right it just doesn't seem like the
business benefits there
and and then you know if you are
if you are going to leak it for some
reason tcr just like you you don't feel
that they are reputable brave like for
felicia
i don't think a tcl conference is going
to come out
with the next hellblade uh surprise demo
right like yo
the funny thing is i i'll i will laugh
my ass off if there is some marketing
deal with xbox
oh pig would go crazy
great let me get recording in here man
this is last time where you at with this
the tcl leaks and
next gen better we ready 2023 2024 what
are you at if y'all ever buy a thing
from any place and think there's not a
v2 already long in development y'all are
tripping you've got to be the most
ignorant people out there like what okay
so here let's go to this i i never
worked on the accessories team but i
think so don't quote me on it i think it
takes about a year
if not a little bit more to get a color
permutation out or a controller wow wow
if you take planning approvals uh
ideation
execution getting the factory signed on
samples approvals again
getting them spun up to go to market
marketing materials and all that just
for a color that's a good point so
to think that they're not already
thinking about what the next generation
of consoles looks like by the time they
have to go to market and
create consoles is silly so i don't care
if we get a mid gen um 20 years ago the
ipod came out and i was like you mean
i don't have a music on cd i have it on
whatever this is 20 years 20 years is
both a long time and not that long right
like 10 years ago i was still using cds
and whatnot and it's
i look at the way that our technology
jumps and leaps and bounds and if they
can find ways to do things more
efficiently so be it i'm here for it yes
do i get annoyed yeah i mean yes i get
annoyed but
it's just kind of the way of the world i
built the pc in march of 2020 and it was
at the beginning of it getting tough to
get video cards
i got a 2080 ti in march and then what
the 30 you know the 3000 series got
announced not long after but that's just
the world yeah that's just it so
i'm sure that this console
has been in
whatever stage of planning like planning
can mean a bunch of things it can mean
paper ideation or it could mean planning
with an actual
uh you know developer and working with
the chips and things oh and that's the
other thing to keep in mind if you're
working with
these companies that have designed for
xbox products well you need to get in to
figure out the tech that they're using
they need to figure out what you're
possibly using and how they can marry
the two
and yeah you both are probably years out
as far as how they got to leaking that
and that's just
i just say
it's not their baby it's xbox's baby so
they're just saying things and oops we
said too much i didn't mean to do that
they had the whole slide show that the
[Applause]
they forget that people have you know
phones on there yeah
and the cameras on their phones
so
are we ready yeah i mean to hear about
it now it's probably not going to be
ready for a couple of years so exactly
if it's well it's midway through 2022 so
if it comes out
mid 24 24 i'm not that mad at that or
you know late 24 early 25 so be it no
fair enough fair enough i see your point
i agree with what you say ricardo
especially we had uh jason rodriguez and
you know we talked about the the design
of the series xs series s and the
iterations of how far the pl they were
already working on that next thing
during the you know the scorpio days and
stuff like it's always to the next thing
and sometimes as gamers we do live in
this pocket but like you said they
they're already with the iterations in
the future whether whatever planning
stages it may be so i do agree with you
on that attic where you're at tcl out
here leaking
but yeah
i mean i i don't know if um they're just
assuming
uh
i don't know if that's going on uh it's
it's like ricardo said like it's
inevitable i i i think you know maybe
maybe we should uh
can you solve the issues with the the
the supply ring we have now before you
know we start doing stuff because i
talked to a developer uh it was like a
year and a half ago
and
they were pretty much like
you'll be developing for a toolkit
and then just one random day they come
in with a new toolkit on the old toolkit
yeah
but this is the thing like like i said
about the wafers moving on to the next
gen thing may be beneficial to getting
more of them out because they're looking
at at smaller cpus and smaller chipsets
so
i just i fear if we keep giving them
this leeway with these mid generations
they're going to be like let's let's do
a phone model every two three years
popping out apart
because what's wrong with that what do
you mean leeway they didn't they didn't
promise you anything nobody promised you
that's a self-imposed reality i'm not
talking about
promising or anything like that i'm
talking about when they come out they
know they're they will do it just
because people will buy it yeah and it's
just like
i had situations where i was on the last
gen stuff there were games that wasn't
functioning correctly on the the xbox
one s
that like i've said it a couple times i
was playing gears of with kid smooth
and
i don't know what was going on but
smooth's game was loading into it faster
and it wouldn't be one of those things
required where it would like have a a
check okay we have to make sure both of
them are loaded
our world will blow first on smooth and
they would be coming in on me to kill me
because i
i'm still in the loading screen the
fight i can't move the fine prince said
it launches on your console that's what
you find that's all it is they didn't
lie to you they did that
so smooth would literally have to
protect me
while i'm in the radius
so it's just like i don't care if they
do
you know gene medjen freshes but it's
like incidences like that
got to be thought of better like because
i feel like when you go into these
scenarios and sure they have years of
experience but they can't they don't
they can't account for all the issues
they're going to have once the consoles
are out yeah yeah it's like true
incidents is like that that it's just
like does this mid-gen stuff really work
like that your concern is lowest common
denominator stuff i know i know what
you're doing i know i'll jump in i'll
look at that i'll make quick look
it's the funniest that is tcl but i do
feel like lacrosse they i think they
must know something you know saying
there must be some
you know dialogue or whatever whatever
now are they all the way outside with
this which i think is hilarious that
it's tcl and them doing it but um yeah
i'm with ricardo i just think it's
inevitable i think you know the mid gen
refresh is is part of the thing now
we've kind of got they got their feet
wet both consoles with it with actually
playstation was first right ps4 pro i
believe and then um
you know then obviously scorpio came on
the xbox one x and look they from my
understanding you know both consoles did
well and it showed that the gamer now
look these things are getting closer to
pc
than you think and i think there is a
market that shows hey there's gamers
that are willing to pay for more power
more performance and there's a market
for it and i think that there's going to
be some gamers maybe the common gamer
that says oh you know what i'm fine it
can run i don't need to do all that but
um i do definitely think we get a
mid-generation refresh i don't know if
it's that quick based on the supply
shortages and obviously the pandemic
effect but i do think it's coming so
it's funny that it's tcl i think it's
hilarious but um yeah get ready get
ready you're gonna have pro pro i just
wanna know what the name and convention
going anyway series x pro x what what
are we doing
what what's what's fronties like names
and stuff can be changed just off of
previous stuff they did because i
remember we had a guest or something i
can't remember which one it was but they
pretty much said that
originally the xbox one x was supposed
to be called xbox elite
but
because they made that elite bundle
right they couldn't use that name so
that's when they went with the xbox one
x yeah and last point i'll say just that
um you know even with the controllers
like ricardo mentioned you know
what i remember seeing the price of the
elite and you know i'm an elite guy i
was like damn that's a high price point
are people gonna pay that much for a
controller and then yo these joints sold
i still couldn't get my gears red elite
one i was mad i wanted that day so fast
but yeah i got over y'all i think he's
gonna jump in before we wrap up
one piece of context that i think kind
of puts you know all you guys on the
right path because you know like to what
ricardi was saying even phil came out
after the uh the one x and said we had a
2017 console planned out like designed
all that stuff so they so both things
can be true like they they could be
designing and probably have been
like phil's already said they're already
designing the next consoles they already
have things in the works it doesn't
always mean though that that's that it's
going to release like right like so they
could have they could have had something
that was targeted for 23 or 24 then
we'll never see the light of day of or
you know maybe we'll find out about down
the road
so there's all kinds of possibilities so
whether something's being planned for
i think the answer is always yes because
they're always planning for those things
especially with as much as they're
investing now but whether that actually
comes out and when it comes out is
probably the bigger question and my
guess is like tcl doesn't know that
because microsoft may not even
be because you know because like they to
even what they've admitted they weren't
sure exactly when they were going to hit
their mid-gen refresh last time right so
just things to keep in mind no doubt so
pretty much what we got let's get up all
the time here oh sorry we got the uh
super chats we're good yeah we got a
couple yeah we got them all right okay
[Music]
we have uh
okay flame we just have flame filled
blame five dollars in pajamas since king
ain't here
um
tcl can't even get that tv rifle how
would they get the information on new
consoles right
that was a good kick impression i gotta
give a flame of that that was messy
definitely king king like i was okay
you're very very king-like
man let's get this whole
new iop poll will be going up later with
the reveal that xbox turned down
marvel's exclusivity offer for
spider-man do you think it was the right
call by microsoft in 2014 to focus on
their own ips the choices are a
no xbox should have jumped on the
opportunity to have their own exclusive
superhero and pop culture game for xbox
b yes xbox was in no position based on
studio health and priorities at the time
to properly take ownership of the
spider-man ip like sony or c i don't
care cuz can xbox please get cog a damn
hashtag just one superhero game so we
don't have to endure these topics every
week please go ahead
when it's up and of course make sure you
salute the legendary ricari austin in
the building rocked the whole time we
kept him hostage
he held it down you know what i'm saying
brother i really appreciate you man a
pleasure to see what you're doing tell
the fine people what you got going on
where they can find you
i got nothing going on oh actually no i
lied hold on you ready for this hold on
three seconds let's go let's go oh sorry
i got it
what are you doing
cooking in the studio oh what's that oh
we got the briefcase what are we doing
you know uh so this is what ricardi does
now i do a lot of stuff for game
gamestop and it's funny they actually
they're renting out my studio my
business and all that so i try to get
back in my content game it's cool but
i've i've leaned into the unboxings and
uh okay
oh okay oh
this is my next one that y'all got to
stay stay on me for i'm always saying
let's go
i believe this is what xbox has been
posting about all over there oh
okay something's cooking that's it
[Laughter]
i love the whole stick i love the energy
the interviews your journey brother
truly inspirational and real like just
real from a standpoint of of of all the
things you went through in the
self-admission with yourself but it's
cool to see you shine brother i'm proud
of you always a pleasure thank you so
much man that was a lot of fun thank you
all for having me i appreciate everybody
no lord obm xbox era pulling up holding
us down when we had lords absent
wasn't sure but you came through for us
you know i
appreciate
folks over there xbox era shout out to
special nick and the team second caico
all of them where can they find you what
you got going on
yeah first of all cog just want to thank
you it's always an honor to be invited
to be with you guys and anytime i can
get here you know i will so thank you i
appreciate you inviting me and by the
way rokari i i was listening to your the
story the whole time it was it's great
it was it's great to be on here with you
man
really inspiring to kind of hear you
know the different different stories and
kind of how you overcame things and i
think that's uh you know a
great thing for anybody that's aspiring
to do different things in their life so
um but if anybody wants to you know get
hold of me i am the senior editor over
at xbox era although great these days i
haven't been putting out content because
i'm working on some behind the scenes
we'll talk more about that later but uh
i do also host a bi-weekly halo show so
if anybody is uh what's the name of it
wants to talk some halo thursdays
thursdays you had me at halo
that's the day i liked that i liked it
you know honestly that was a show that
started because of the name
i love it love it
so
uh so yeah we got that going on and uh
if anybody wants other than that you
know i pop into different podcasts so
you know if you want to follow me on
twitter at one bad mother at mother
m-u-t-h-a underscore o-n-e uh just
follow me there and um i'm sure you'll
find me you know pop it up in somebody
else's podcast sometime soon but great
being on with you guys thanks again
always a present always appreciate the
knowledge and the love man thanks for
pulling up always get the podcast with
your brother and of course lord addict
lord nyquil himself are we
i appreciate it i'm glad you're feeling
better man thanks for pulling up uh
pretty good i think sarah carr for
coming on is a pretty good show man i'm
sorry i missed the first 45 minutes
what's funny is i woke up and i looked
at the
uh the time of my oven and i was like oh
i i'm good i'm like it starts like 45
bucks
then i turned my pc on and i was like
that that don't say one
you look at the club like
i'm like okay so wait wait wait you said
pc
and oven clock where is the alarm
the phone was there the phone yeah
yeah appreciate everyone for coming
through man uh you know next week we are
having our xbox press uh prediction show
uh so i'm sure it's gonna go a lot into
that this week
i will be streaming it takes two with my
girl this afternoon so uh that should be
interesting
let's get the relationship problems out
let's go you can use the controller so
we got that going for us okay
uh so definitely uh look forward to that
i'll be streaming on my channel gaming
addict uh that should be interesting
uh and yeah we we we definitely have
some stuff planned for you next week man
i'm sure it's gonna be a pretty chaotic
show i will make uh a um
next week's gonna be a long time
yeah yeah we don't know what next
weekend we know it next year and i and i
have i do have some some surprises
but i'm still in the middle of making
them but i appreciate everyone coming
through and we'll we'll see you next
week for like the six hour show yeah
she's going to be nuts
off looking to find people finding what
you got going on sir yeah first off big
shout out to one bad mother for coming
through always a pleasure to get your
takes on stuff on the show
um and rakari man like i gotta say i'm
always super partial to people whose
stories resemble ours right this idea
where you come from sort of not defining
who you are and uh
early on when when kag was trying to
give you flowers about you know being
the first of mine or whatever and you
you pushed back a little bit and said
it's just it's pride right but i think
you know we talked a lot about maturity
and not being ready for the
opportunities that are presented to us
and i think a lot of times what happens
is when we're young that pride
kind of evolves into drive right and i
think that's key to your story like
you see the opportunities you finally
were at the maturity level where you
could understand where they could take
you and you took them and you ran with
it and then at the same time
you think about we you learn about your
own worth you're like okay now i could
do this for myself
and
i'm not gonna under i'm not i'm not
gonna kind of undersell myself yeah
yeah because for us like we see you
initially when you left xbox for us oh
damn whatever but you see how it opens
up different doors for you and now you
have more freedom kind of than you ever
had um and now you can sort of write
your own checks so a fantastic story man
i wish you nothing but the best and
obviously we'll be following your career
so you already know thank you ma'am
salute thank you salute that's all i got
everybody enjoy your sunday memorial day
all that good stuff and uh yeah next
week will be a big one probably the
prediction show shout out oh someone
just came in is that the last year yeah
okay yeah we gotta go
okay
necromancers ale ten dollar sweet chat
xbox needs more of the burgers fries and
shakes this generation no they do not
they're good yes we do that we had
enough gears halo forza we we thank you
everybody look unless it's like one of
those
pristine burgers i don't want it i'm
buying unless it's tactics too that i
might be exactly okay what else we got
yeah we got lord metroid two dollars by
the way the pax east coverage was
excellent thank you thank you sir
appreciate that that that coverage
almost killed me yeah we killed this we
definitely yeah we're glad you guys
enjoyed it shout out to audible he's on
twitch right now watching this he said i
caught y'all moonwalk that's the guy
that does the beats for us then you got
necromancy again i always say that ohio
cuisine was good though yes
one last one then we gotta go n necroman
to zelo five dollars super chat cog you
need to get maddie on board for more of
xbox's burgers fries and shakes last
show when you were talking about it i'm
not happy i agree with maddie i agree
with maddie forget about that yeah
who knows maybe he'll be on that who
knows where we live we see daddy
look everybody enjoy your sunday we up
out of here peace
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you